welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine
today my guest is Dr Robert malenka Dr
Robert malenka is a professor of
Psychiatry and Behavioral Sciences at
Stanford University School of Medicine
he is both a medical doctor in MD and a
researcher a PhD
his laboratory is famous for having
discovered some of the key components
allowing neuroplasticity that is the
nervous system's ability to change in
response to experience in addition Dr
malenka's research is considered Central
to the textbook knowledge about how
reward systems in the brain are
organized and function indeed Dr
malenko's research over the last 10 or
15 years has merged what was once two
disparate Fields the first being the
study of neuroplasticity again the
nervous system's ability to change in
response to experience and the other
field being the field of dopamine as it
relates to pleasure and addiction his
laboratory is shown for instance that
when we seek out particular forms of
pleasure regardless of whether or not
they are healthy for us that changes the
way that our reward circuitry works and
actually changes the way that dopamine
is released and how it impacts the brain
and his work has also informed how we
seek out healthy Pleasures including
healthy food and social connection
today's discussion explores all of these
topics and by the end of today's
discussion you will have a rich
understanding of how neurochemicals like
dopamine and serotonin work in parallel
to reinforce that is to increase the
probability that we will engage in
certain types of thinking and behaviors
so if you are somebody interested in
neuroplasticity that is how the nervous
system can change in response to
experience and or you are interested in
reward systems what motivates us and
what we are likely to pursue in the
future given our choices of past and if
you are interested in things like social
connection and empathy or lack thereof
today's discussion encompasses all of
those topics it is worth mentioning that
Dr malenka is a true luminary in all of
the fields I just mentioned as well as
several other fields in fact when you
look out on the landscape of modern
Neuroscience what you'll discover is
that a very large percentage of the top
Laboratories studying neuroplasticity
and reward systems and so on all stemmed
from having trained in Dr malanka's
Laboratory so it's a real honor and
pleasure to be able to host him today
and I'm sure that our discussion is
going to greatly enrich the way that you
think about brain function
neuroplasticity and reward before we
begin I'd like to emphasize that this
podcast is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
Roca Roca makes eyeglasses and
sunglasses that are the absolute highest
quality the company was founded by two
All-American swimmers from Stanford and
everything about Roka eyeglasses and
sunglasses were designed with
performance in mind I've spent a
lifetime working on the biology of the
visual system and I can tell you that
your visual system has to contend with
an enormous number of challenges in
order for you to be able to see clearly
Roca understands those challenges and
the biology the visual system such that
they've designed sunglasses and
Eyeglasses that always allow you to see
with Crystal clarity now initially Roca
glasses and sunglasses were designed for
sports performance and as a consequence
all of their glasses are designed to be
very lightweight and to not slip off
your face if you get sweaty however the
design of the glasses include some that
are specifically for sport and others
whose aesthetic really allows you to use
them for sport as well as out to dinner
or to work etc and that's how I use them
if you'd like to try Roca eyeglasses and
sunglasses you can go to roca.com that's
roka.com and enter the code huberman to
save 20 off your first order again
that's Roca roka.com and enter the code
huberman at checkout today's episode is
also brought To Us by levels levels is a
program that lets you see how different
foods and behaviors affect your health
by giving you real-time feedback on your
diet using a continuous glucose monitor
one of the most important factors
impacting your immediate and long-term
health is the way that your body manages
its blood glucose or sometimes referred
to as blood sugar levels to maintain
energy and focus throughout the day you
want to keep your blood glucose steady
without big spikes or dips using levels
you can monitor how different types of
foods and different food combinations as
well as food timing and things like
exercise combined to impact your blood
glucose levels I started using levels a
little over a year ago and it gave me a
lot of insight into how specific Foods
were spiking my blood sugar and then
leaving me feeling tired for several
hours afterwards as well as how the
spacing of exercise and my meals was
impacting my overall energy and in doing
so it really allowed me to optimize how
I eat what I eat when I exercise and so
on such that my blood glucose levels and
energy levels are stable throughout the
day if you're interested in learning
more about levels and trying a
continuous glucose monitor yourself go
to levels.link huberman right now levels
is offering an additional two free
months of membership again that's
levels.link l-i-n-k slash huberman to
get two free months of membership and
now for my discussion with Dr Robert
malenka Dr malenka Rob welcome yeah
thanks for having me delighted to have
you here both for sake of your medical
knowledge and training as a psychiatrist
and of course as a luminary in the field
of neuroplasticity dopamine and reward
systems social systems your knowledge of
autism and social interactions
a newer interest in or perhaps old
interest in psychedelics and what
they're doing and potential for mental
health there are just so many things
that you've done in this field I've been
a long long time fan of your work since
your days as an assistant professor I've
tracked your career I've learned a
tremendous amount from you by observing
you and
from being your colleague so really
delighted to have you here you're making
me blush and I don't blush easily well
it's all true and I and I will say as
well you've also trained an enormous
number of incredible scientists
um Carl diceroff the Carl diceroth Anna
Lemke always speaks incredibly highly of
you as a mentor and I'm somebody she's
learned a tremendous amount from and
pretty much anyone that's worked on
neuroplasticity on dopamine and reward
systems addiction and now in the fields
of autism and soon psychedelics as well
references as you often and you've been
mentioned many times before on this
podcast if not by name by work so again
thank you for being here I'd love to
kick off the conversation by talking
about something which is very
fundamental to everything we're going to
talk about but certainly fundamental to
our daily lives which is dopamine yeah
we hear so much about dopamine people
talk about dopamine hits people think
about dopamine is pleasure dopamine
reward
for the novice how how would you frame
the dopamine system I mean it but does a
bunch of different things in different
areas of the brain and body but to you
what what does dopamine represent as its
major function in the brain and could
you give us a kind of General Contour of
the neural circuits that allow this
chemical to more or less put value on
our experiences yeah that's very well
put
um
as you point out dopamine is one of the
major what we term neuromodulators in
the brain a chemical signaling messenger
that the brain uses to mediate a complex
array of actions it's best well-known
function is in what we call the brain's
reward circuitry so this is a circuit in
the brain and when we use the term
circuit what we really mean is one part
of the brain communicating with another
part of the brain because the brain is
this very complex you know it's the most
complex organism organ in the universe
with lots of different nerve cells
talking to each other simultaneously and
as neuroscientists we try to parse what
different brain areas are doing and what
different neuromodulators might be doing
and dopamine was discovered oh I should
know this many decades ago
um and it's it's as I said the major
chemical messenger
molecule in the so-called brain's reward
circuitry and when you're talking about
so what is the brain's reward circuitry
this is a part of the brain
that tells us something is reinforcing
in our environment some stimuli or
in quotes is rewarding makes us feel
better or good although that's a gross
oversimplification and before getting
into the details of dopamine and its
function in the reward circuitry I think
it's useful to talk about why do we need
a reward circuitry why do we need
something in our brain
that tells us this feels good or this
feels bad and it goes back to Evolution
I I am a biological scientist that means
I believe in evolution
and if you think about the evolution of
our species
everything is driven by
developing mechanisms that increase our
survival and it's really useful you need
something in your nervous system that
tells you some stimuli in your
environment is important for your
survival or some stimulus in your
environment is dangerous so it's not
magic that
um
sugary high fat Laden foods are highly
reinforcing and rewarding rewarding it's
not an accident there has to be a
mechanism in the brain that tells us
that it's not an accident that most of
the time for most of us a sexual
experience is pretty reinforcing is
pretty rewarding it's not an accident
that warmth feels really good when
you're cold that water tastes much
better when you're really thirsty there
have what evolved is a mechanism to tell
our nervous systems and tell our brains
this feels pretty good I should repeat
the behavior that leads to that
rewarding experience and similarly it's
really important when
you you know there is an event in your
life that's highly dangerous for some
mechanism in your brain to say whoa I
don't want to go back to where that lion
was and we can get into that so this was
a long-rounded way of saying what the
reward circuitry tells us is this event
this stimulus it could be an external
stimulus
like I said a you know a Krispy Kreme
donut which I happen to love and I have
to be very disciplined so I don't eat
too many of them
um it could be a drug of abuse and maybe
we'll talk about that a little bit
all of these stimuli seem to activate
and cause the release of dopamine in
this brain reward circuitry so now we
need to get into a little bit of detail
neuroscientists use these
very unfriendly terms to describe
different brain regions so the home of
dopamine cells or brain cells are called
neurons so the home of dopamine neurons
are in a part of the brain sort of what
we call the lower midbrain
the dopamine neurons that are part of
the reward circuitry are found in this
area called the ventral tegmental area
which I'm sorry to have to use such
technical jargon and we call it the VTA
that's the acronym I think the roof of
the midbrain is the tectum it means roof
and the base of the midbrain it means
floor which is tegmentum I think that's
the so there's a rationale but it
doesn't help much at all to know the
names and in fact you are absolutely
correct and I always forget that so
thank you for pointing that out it's a
it's a side effect of teaching
neuronatives and then uh which I once
did back in the early the 80s but I've
forgotten everything I taught
um anyhow so these dopamine neurons and
we can talk about other types of
dopamine neurons they send messages what
we call projections I'm using Telegraph
wires that we call axons they send
projections to many different brain
regions the key one in the brain's
reward circuitry being an area again
with a very complicated name called the
nucleus accumbens and maybe Andrew you
know I actually don't know how that name
evolved the nucleus accumbens and I'm
sure I should know because I've been
studying it for 30 years but I have
never looked up the Genesis of that name
well the fortunate thing about this
podcast is it's both on audio platforms
like Spotify and apple but also on
YouTube and so now we can be absolutely
sure that somebody has put it into the
YouTube comments underneath this episode
and therefore everyone will learn
including us so I don't know origins of
the word nucleus
um and the it's it's a gross
oversimplification but it's the activity
of these dopamine neurons in the ventral
tegmental area
that then cause the release of this
powerful neuromodulated
neuromodulator dopamine in the nucleus
accumbens which has a is part of another
brain structure with a
tough to remember name called the
ventral striatum and then magic happens
and when I say magic happens even though
we've been studying how dopamine
modifies the properties of cells in this
nucleus accumbens the truth is we don't
have a deep mechanistic understanding
why when dopamine is released in the
nucleus accumbens we experience that as
I'm being very cautious here the simple
way would be to say as highly rewarding
but it's a little more complicated than
that what what it tells us is that
there's something really important
happening in our environment
um so Dan could we say that it cues the
arousal system it it it gets the arousal
system going and there's close ties to
our memory systems which hopefully
intuitively makes some sense if
something really important is happening
in your environment because again we I I
think what's helpful for your audience
is to always be thinking about how these
systems evolved from an evolutionary
perspective and if dopamine is signaling
something really important and Salient
is happening in your environment you
want to remember that it could be a
highly rewarding experience like a
source of food for me it's a Chris I
like all Donuts so I don't want to I do
too emphasize eyes any one manufacturer
of one donut versus the other I I like
sugar Laden fat Laden Foods that's why I
never eaten them because I like them so
much and I use that as an example but
because that was an important event for
my survival this reward circuitry yes it
stimulates my arousal system it gets me
to pay attention it also has very close
ties to memory systems I mean to go off
on a little bit of a tangent I think the
one
um I don't want to say it's a mistake I
think perhaps somewhat over
simplification of how people
conceptualize
dopamine's role in the brain is even
though it's a major important role is
for it to be active and released during
highly reinforcing experiences like sex
like really good food like drugs of
abuse it also can get activated
subdivisions of this system during
painful stimuli and during aversive
stimuli which again are really important
for you to be aware of to say oh my God
that's really bad for me
um and so the dopamine system this
reward circuitry and its sub components
that maybe
perhaps signal more salience or a
version aversion in the environment are
closely tied to arousal systems and
memory systems
again hopefully for somewhat obvious
reasons you want to remember
powerfully reinforcing events in your
life as well as powerfully emotionally
or physically painful events in your
life so I hope I answered
your question to a modest degree no
um far better than a monastery that
that's an excellent description of the
dopamine system from a true expert and
the question I have is about some of the
context and Nuance of the system but in
in sort of real world terms how how
should I think about this even in my
training as a neuroscientist I know
neurons can be a little active a lot
active everything in between they can be
active over long periods of time or
short periods of time but let's use the
example of the donut I'm I like a glazed
fashion donut I actually don't have a
craving for sweet things but Donuts is
is an exception I like the glazel
fashioned donut but if I were to see
just a little piece of a glazed
old-fashioned donut
versus a full glazed old-fashioned donut
could I expect that more dopamine is
released to the anticipation of the
complete donut and then the other
question is how does context influence
the dopamine system for instance if I'm
very full a glazed old-fashioned donut
might be aversive to me or as if I'm
just a little bit hungry or if I'm
actually more on a schedule of rewarding
myself for abstaining from sweet fatty
foods then abstaining from the food
might be its own form of reward yeah I
mean and so to me the dopamine system
seems incredibly simple and yet
incredibly prone to immediate context
and the kinds of nuance that I mean
we're constantly juggling I'll interrupt
myself to say that we're constantly
juggling a bunch of different reward
contingencies we want to you know have
good health metrics and maybe have a
certain aesthetic quality to our body
but we also want the donut and so how
does a sim a system as simple as a one
neuromodulator system and the VTA to
nucleus accumbens and with some
connections to the memory area
how does it balance all of that
information in real time to me that's
just like staggeringly complex but also
incredibly interesting
um I I think you beautifully put very
eloquent description
um you just said it it's staggeringly
simple simultaneously staggeringly
complex and you you asked several
different questions so context makes an
enormous importance and that's one of
the reasons I became interested in the
dopamine reward circuitry is as you know
as a colleague in the academic
Neuroscience world but your listeners
probably don't I started out my career
studying very basic mechanisms of
plasticity how does the brain modify
itself and what makes the brain
different than compute the computer
hardware is are the physical
Connections in the brain are constantly
changing the strength of the
communication
similarly for their dopamine reward
circuitry it's highly plastic and it's
highly contextually dependent
um
and so you gave the example of donuts
and feeding and I'll answer your
question about the cues
um yes it's I used to give the example
of Thanksgiving so let me give that
example you know in the morning of
Thanksgiving all
for most of us in the United States
um the morning of Thanksgiving if you're
at home visiting your parents the smells
of the apple pie the smells of the
turkey cooking are highly repetitive
highly reinforcing you're anticipating
that fun event you're anticipating Uncle
Joe coming to visit you for Thanksgiving
and that's all because these cues the
smells the anticipation of Uncle Joe's
your previous experiences are part are
part of your memory system sort of
talking to
in a simple way your reward circuitry so
you're building up this anticipation one
can almost say this craving which maybe
we'll talk about in the context of
addiction and then make a long story
short think about
that evening at the end of Thanksgiving
those exact same cues the exact same
smell of the apple pie turkey and Uncle
Joe himself at the very least they're no
longer repetitive meaning they might
actually be aversive the last thing you
want is the piece of apple pie you can't
wait for Uncle Joe to leave your
Thanksgiving dinner and I always argue
that does not happen magically that
happens because your brain has been
modified by the context in which it sits
and this very important modulatory
system this reward circuitry is
responding to the exact same stimuli
with a very different response so that
I'm just telling you I'm repeating what
you said the phenomenology and and again
my other favorite example is any of us
who have been in an intimate
relationship knows that the love of your
life can turn to the bane of your
existence in 20 seconds
um and again that doesn't happen
magically this person who you crave who
you love does something and two minutes
later your brain is saying oh my God
I you know I may have to break up with
this person or this is an incredibly
painful experience emotional experience
and what fascinates me about the brain
is how does the brain mediate that rapid
change so now back to so yes context
makes
is everything about how this powerful
neuromodual Choice system that uses
dopamine works and the truth is we don't
know it's because the inputs onto these
dopamine neurons the other nerve cells
that are driving the activity of the
dopamine neurons and I've actually
studied this in my lab at Stanford
University with a colleague you know
well lychun luo who's a a world-class
neuroscientist
um we've studied the complexity of the
neuroanatomy of the dopamine system and
these dopamine neurons in the ventral
tegmental area this the the source of
the reward circuitry dopamine are
receiving inputs from all over the brain
they're receiving you know indirectly or
directly inputs from visual areas from
somatosensory areas
um and I'm not giving you a really good
answer because that's one of the goals
of my research to try to understand how
context how the history that you've had
with these cues which we're going to get
back to of the donut or of a drug how is
that modified how this neuromodulatory
system responds similarly the the
nucleus accumbens the the target of this
powerful modulator dopamine
is receiving
Communications what we call inputs from
all sorts of brain regions that you know
about Andrew your audience may not it
receives inputs from an area called the
hippocampus which you may have covered
in previous podcasts which is very
powerfully very important for memories
both establishing new memories and again
remember that makes sense you want this
system this dopamine reward circuitry to
be very connected to memory systems so
the the nucleus accumbens the activity
in the nucleus succumbens is modulated
by dopamine while it is receiving
information from the hippocampus which
helps encode new memories while it's
receiving information from a brain area
called the amygdala which tells is a
part of the brain involved in our
emotional experiences the accumbens also
receives inputs from the prefrontal
cortex which is this brain area as you
know better than me Andrew is important
for
decision making for planning our
activity and I could go on and on we
talk about prefrontal cortex for a
moment um because
um
always
was surprising to me that prefrontal
cortex is talked about as this higher
executive function area but then when
you look at the neuroanatomy it's
as we say monosynaptically as you and I
know with one connection
um away from structures like the
amygdala one connection away from
structures like the the nucleus that
comes in other words prefrontal cortex
to me is every bit as ancient
um as some of these other structures
that we think of as more ancient and
really the whole ancient evolve thing
gets a little bit dicey because certain
areas are like the prefrontal cortex are
more elaborated in humans but but to me
the prefrontal cortex seems to be
especially important in the context of
this thing of scaling the reward
response or context
of the reward response because
it can set rules it seems to know
um okay we're recording a podcast now
and there are certain rules there's
certain things we're going to do and not
do
um but what's fascinating about the and
I'm so glad you gave a bunch of
different examples because what's
fascinating for instance about the uh
the relationship example is that yes at
one moment
um we can adore somebody in another
moment later if they do something or
don't do something we can be incredibly
frustrated with them they can even
become aversive to us hopefully that
doesn't happen too frequently hopefully
but
um I think we've all had the experience
of a donut an event or a person actually
looking different to us in a you know
from one moment to the next hopefully
not at random right and so to me it
seems like
um the prefrontal cortex is uniquely
positioned to really say okay right now
we are in a mode of
for lack of a better word love and
loving like be in the in the verb tense
of loving or be in the verb tense of
arguing we're now arguing you know we're
in the verb tense of of reconciliation
you know kind of somewhere in between or
something of that sort and
how a structure in a circuit as simple
as the dopamine system right one
molecule could suddenly say oh you know
what now getting over my anger is
rewarding whereas five minutes ago being
right and being the most angry was
rewarding and then five minutes before
that again we're accelerating this movie
but five minutes or five days or five
years before that this person could do
no wrong and the dopamine system is just
cracking out dopamine saying whatever
you do I'm just delighted by it
incredible yeah like to me I can't think
of a more interesting system in
Neuroscience well I mean that was
eloquently put
um I agree with pretty much everything
you said I don't have much to add
because what you're pointing out is
the challenges of studying these systems
the importance of studying these systems
and the challenge of presenting how the
brain works to this podcast audience
because on the one hand
you have done a mark in a fantastic job
over the last few years in your podcast
of making complex
um subjects accessible to a lay audience
um
and get them to be thinking about how
our modern view of how the brain works
may could be used to enhance Health
could enhance mental well-being but as
neuroscientists academic neuroscientists
ourselves we we know you know you are
oversimplifying things and the actual
functioning of a system like the
dopamine reward circuitry as you just
eloquently point out is so much more
complex
it's Modified by these prefrontal
inputs which are simultaneously telling
our memory systems you know pay
attention here
I'm repeating what you just said the
context makes a big difference the
history you have with
the person or stimuli with whom you're
interacting like to bring this back to
you and you know which I never the
initial question is a small piece of a
donut activate the cue that that small
piece of a donut and activate the reward
circuitry and cause release of dopamine
to the same extent as the full donut
it depends on your experience with
donuts I mean I think for you and me
because we seem to both have you know
like donuts they're highly repetitive
for us
um probably doesn't matter because we
have learned even a little piece of a
donut it activates all of our memory
systems saying man that's an
old-fashioned glazed donut I want to eat
that I want to get one or I want to have
the discipline not to eat it
um so I hope I'm answering questions and
I'm shifting topics completely but
that's why addiction is so challenging
well let's talk about that um let's talk
about that because you've done a ton of
important work in this area of addiction
I mean one of the basic questions I have
about addiction is you know we hear that
certain drugs are more addicting than
other drugs or certain behaviors we also
hear that we can become addicted to
anything when on a Lemke was on this
podcast
um I said what's the most unusual
addiction you've ever seen and she
talked about a patient who sadly
committed suicide at some point later
that she she told us had been addicted
to water to drinking of any kind first
alcohol but then water eventually
um and so so my question about addiction
in the dopamine system is you know for
let's pick a drug
um Like Cocaine
um I've never done cocaine
um but people who have done cocaine tell
me that it feels very good
um and one of the more Salient features
of the cocaine high is that it comes on
very fast and it ends pretty quickly too
is the rate of dopamine increase
related to The Addictive property of a
drug or behavior as much as how much
dopamine is released and that's a very
sophisticated question and the answer is
yes and that's usually the uh the
lecture I give the way I think about
addiction
um and obviously my friend and colleague
Anna Lemke is one of the world's experts
in terms of the understanding The Human
Experience of addiction I have studied
it as a cellular molecular
neuroscientists trying to understand
how addictive substances
modify reward circuitry modify the
connections and the reward circuitry
modify how dopamine neurons Act and the
way I you know like any what appears to
be a simple term it's layered with
complexity
addiction is somewhat of a Continuum and
I like to think about whether you're
talking about substances like cocaine
and I will explicitly answer your
questions soon or opioids as we as you
know we're going in this country there
is an opioid epidemic I I do like to
think about addictive liability and it
is in my view it is pretty clear that
when we're talking about drugs they have
different degrees of addictive liability
I mean I had a cup of coffee this
morning am I a and many of us listening
to this podcast
it's really hard to start our day
without getting that hit of caffeine but
are we addicted to caffeine that's a
tricky question because I've never heard
of anybody robbing a bank to get
caffeine
destroying their personal life to get
caffeine so I would say caffeine causes
tolerance but I would not say it has a
particularly High addictive liability
whereas drugs like psycho stimulants
Like Cocaine have a very or opioids have
a very high addictive liability so to
answer your mechanistic question there
have been some famous studies done
by the director of the National
Institute on drug abuse Nora volkov
simultaneously there have been studies
in animal models of addiction where you
nailed it the in a rough way The
Addictive liability of a substance is
directly correlate it with two aspects
of dopamine how much dopamine is
released in the incumbens and the
kinetics of the dopamine well he says
you said how rapidly it's released to
get a little technical even with the
drug like cocaine or opioids it's not
only the drug itself it's the root of
administration because the root of
administration influences the kinetics
meaning how fast that drugs gets into
your brain
influences the reward circuitry and how
fast it causes a big Rapid Release of
dopamine and some of your podcast
listeners may be old enough to remember
the crack cocaine epidemic or freebase
cocaine and cocaine does have like
methamphetamine a very high addictive
liability I teach the neurobi I give
lectures to students at Stanford about
neurobiology of addiction as part of a
team course
team taught course I have kids who I had
to deal with and well you know what I
always say is you know you it's not that
if you use this drug you're
automatically going to become an addict
but
you're taking that risk and it is
impossible to become addicted to a
substance if you've never used it by
definition but back to the root of
administration so I I went off that's
actually an interesting statement um you
know because I think we may have heard
that in high school although I
um to be honest wasn't the most
attentive high school student and I
regret that high school students
eventually I came around but but there
was an uphill battle there
um but you that you can't become
addicted to something that you've never
done which
um I just want to earmark that because I
think it's a profound statement because
it points to the importance of the
memory system but also plasticity and so
I I want to make sure that eventually we
get around to talking about how
um the amount of dopamine released in
the kinetics how that might influence
plasticity basically what I'm asking
here queuing up in the back your mind is
whether or not addiction is just related
to The Sensation that we have when we
indulge in a behavior or when we are
under the influence of a drug or whether
or not it actually modifies neural
circuitry in a way that
um makes a broader range of uh drugs or
experiences attractive to us it's
probably the latter but so let me get
back and I will answer that in a second
to the point I was making so it's not
only the substance it's the root of
administration so and uh
you know as I said you can't develop a
problem with the substance and develop a
substance abuse problem if you never
take it but snorting cocaine is a
different experience than smoking it or
injecting it and one of the reasons the
crack cocaine
um epidemic was so powerful is
it it gets into when you're smoking it
or injecting it it gets in and and
people do this now with methamphetamine
I mean meth addicts most of them and
that is another epidemic in our country
most of them smoke it and that the
danger of that is the drug whether it's
cocaine methamphetamine gets into your
brain
almost instantaneously causes a very
rapid powerful surge of dopamine in the
accumbens in this reward circuitry and
that the feeling you get which and we're
going to get into this is not
necessarily A Happy Feeling
and it only lasts it can last for tens
of seconds or a few minutes and it's a
feeling that
for gives you this overwhelming
compulsion and urge I want to do it
again but so even though it may not
actually feel all that good it's it's a
real and again this gets into you know
we didn't have an addiction problem
for any substance other than alcohol
um
you know for most of Humanity's
existence because these substances Like
Cocaine methamphetamine synthetic
opioids like fentanyl they didn't exist
and our brain you know the truth is our
brains are we're not are not designed to
handle those kinds of very powerful
substances as many of you know I've been
taking ag-1 daily since 2012. so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast ag1 is a vitamin mineral
probiotic drink that's designed to meet
all of your foundational nutrition needs
now of course I try to get enough
servings of vitamins and minerals
through whole food sources that include
vegetables and fruits every day but
oftentimes I simply can't get enough
servings but with ag1 I'm sure to get
enough vitamins and minerals and the
probiotics that I need and it also
contains adaptogens to help buffer
stress simply put I always feel better
when I take ag1 I have more focus and
energy and I sleep better and it also
happens to taste great for all these
reasons whenever I'm asked if you could
take Just One supplement what would it
be I answer ag1 if you'd like to try ag1
go to drinkag1.com huberman to claim a
special offer they'll give you five free
travel packs plus a year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again that's drink ag1.com
huberman
so where do you want to go from here you
asked a question about you know the the
neural mechanisms of the of what we call
addiction yeah I'd like to know about
the role of neuroplasticity and
addiction I I do want to highlight
something you said and I apologize for
um interrupting a moment ago but it was
an interruption based on real excitement
because a
um uh a person I know quite well who is
a recovered cocaine addict told me and
that by the way folks this isn't I have
a friend and I'm actually you know I
truly have never tried cocaine
um and this person said that the first
time they did cocaine
his thought was I hate this and I can't
wait to do it again and that's exactly
how you described it and I think that is
a fairly common experience with people
suffering from an addiction disorder
we're not supposed to use the word
addicts anymore because that's a little
bit judgmental and that's the new
nomenclature that's something along
those lines I'm calling someone an
addict you know as opposed to being
addicted yeah being uh got it and
um that is a beautiful description I
hate it but I want to do it again
um and again it just shows the pot the
power of this system which remember
evolved for our survival
so a very simple way of thinking about
it is these drugs are tricking the
reward circuitry to say this stimulus
this experience is really important for
my survival I have to go do it again and
again and again a side question is the
huge question is why do some people
develop an addiction problem and others
who have used this substance just don't
um and as again as a world-class
neuroscientist yourself you know the
answer it's always a complex combination
of underlying genetics the environment
in which they find themselves the
environment in which they grew up and
how that modified their reward circuitry
so to get at your question
um
one set of experiments my lab did which
other labs did too I don't deserve the
sole credit for this is showing that
drugs of abuse
cause powerful plasticity in the neurons
that make up the cells that make up the
reward circuitry and in fact drugs of
abuse Like Cocaine methamphetamine
opioids like morphine heroin
change the what the synapses the
synapses are the connections
from other nerve cells onto dopamine
neurons onto the nerve cells and the
accumbens and these connections these
synapses can change and drugs of abuse
cause powerful changes in those
connections and therefore powerful
changes in the activity of the dopamine
neurons and the neurons in the in the
ventral in the in the nucleus accumbens
and in fact the types of changes that
occur appear to be similar to the types
of changes that have evolved for
good uses for adaptive forms of learning
and memory
so again this is an example that this
superficially simple dopamine reward
circuitry
is changing all the time it is highly
plastic and can become more sensitive to
certain experiences you know etc etc
well could I ask a question about some
of the general Contours of the
plasticity in the dopamine system you
said before and I love this statement
even though it's very simple but in its
Simplicity it's really elegant that we
can't become addicted to a substance or
a behavior that we haven't taken or
partaken in so
is there data to support the idea that
just one exposure
to cocaine or one exposure to some sort
of behavior
can lead to a lasting change in the
dopamine system such that one's
propensity to be addicted to that
substance
again if one were to indulge in the
future or behavior again in the future
is increased and I have a very
particular reason for asking this but
I'm very curious what the answer is I
mean in in the work my lab and other
labs have done in
pre-clinical rodent models the answer is
yes a single administration of a drug of
abuse
Like Cocaine like morphine can cause
relatively several days several weeks
of changes in the connections onto
dopamine neurons and on to the neurons
in the nucleus accumbens
those changes that does not mean these
changes are permanent or
um or irreversible but the changes last
a long time
um and again the big question for
understanding the neurobiology of
addiction is you know those changes are
probably happening in most people who
take the drug in this case and we can
talk about other stimuli non-drug
stimuli that can become in quotes
addictive you know again why in certain
individuals
to be honest it's not a big deal yeah I
did cocaine at this party it was nice
but I don't feel any craving or urge to
do it again whereas other individuals it
sets them down you know a very bad path
and really badly affects their life and
that's a huge question in the research
field because obviously if we could make
predictions on which individuals
are more susceptible
and you know not to get too political
here
um but it's also you know whether you
become developer problem with addiction
or not is influenced by the other
parts of your life do you have other
ways of getting reinforcing stimuli
getting satisfaction having an outlet
that other ways of activating your
reward or dopamine circuitry you know
healthy ways right like you know as you
have articulated I think in in your
podcast getting exercise you know you
and I both like to get exercise I feel
really good sometimes it's painful
during the exercise but afterwards I
feel great
um almost the inverse of the cocaine
response yeah um yeah and the desire and
then the I hate this but I can't wait to
do it again it seems like exercise is
often the opposite because I hate this I
don't want to do this and then
afterwards gosh I always feel better and
I'd be happy to do it again I mean yes I
mean I like to exercise chasing a ball
that because that gets me off
thinking about this hurts but um so
anyhow back to addiction um
so yes these drugs can cause
yeah I don't want to definitely not
permanent changes from a single exposure
um you know and and the types of studies
I'm talking about were all done in you
know experimental animals so how that
relates to what happens in our brains in
human subjects brains is it's not
completely clear but I think there are
parallels so the changes might last you
know a few days a week or two
um but one can see if somebody
there have been studies done where in an
animal model if you give repeated
administration of a drug like cocaine
the changes get stronger and they last
longer which is kind of intuitively
obvious
um but again the big question is why
um
in human subjects there are people who
can use these substances and not develop
a serious problem and there are others
where they're they're very very damaging
um and you know and then that's why I
still make the point if you're a young
person if you're do you want to take
that risk is it worth it
um to have that experience and that's an
individual decision we've got we've done
some podcast episodes about alcohol
cannabis Etc and there just seem to be a
pretty wide variation in people's
response to the information I think
because there are people out there who
well I've got friends who are recovered
alcoholics who will tell me the first
drink they took yep they use language
like
you know it combined with the um
chemistry of my body in a way that
nothing before ever had
and they felt like it was like this
magic Elixir right that has not been my
experience and I
and I've heard the same stories and it's
it's hard for me to relate because like
you alcohol does not
have that effect on me and that's where
that's it's hard to believe that kind of
immediate response to alcohol is due to
their in the environments in which they
grew up although that can have an
influence that just feels almost more
genetically encoded and there is
evidence that
issues with
the use of alcohol and developing
alcohol use disorder does run in
families and obviously if it runs in
family you have to worry about how the
environment of that family influences
there's a lot of studies saying there is
a genetic component
um maybe like you if I have a drink or
two in the afternoon I just fall asleep
yeah and it does not have that effect on
me and
um and anyone can imagine similar things
for other drugs of abuse there are
people who have used cocaine have used
methamphetamine who you know who find it
modestly enjoyable but it's not you know
the be all or end all it is in this
incredibly powerful experience and you
just talked about I think a friend or a
colleague who said I hate it I hate that
but I want to do it again and that's
fascinating they're now a recovered uh
alcoholic and cocaine addict and they've
they've abstained for many years but
still get a little bit of a gleam in
their eye when they talk about
alcohol or cocaine in a way that I just
can't relate to
um I mean can I tell you a little
vignette about me which I love to tell
um sure and it gets into how the reward
circuitry is so closely associated with
memory systems and how cues
associate it with powerful experiences
develop their own reinforcing or
aversive quality so long story short
when I was a young kid
and I can't remember in my 20s maybe 20
I spent a few weeks in Paris I started
smoking cigarettes I mean this is a long
time ago and I got it's cigarettes are
very interesting nicotine is highly
addictive as our as the tobacco
companies were fully aware of high
addictive liability very high addictive
Library people will rob people for the
money to buy cigarettes um
they may not Rob because although my
understanding has become quite expensive
but I guess that's a vote significant
counterfeit cigarettes are a huge market
for organized crime there are certain
parts of our of our in the world third
world countries where organized crime
produce counterfeit cigarettes and are
making hundreds of millions or billions
of dollars
um and
so I think nicotine as it is delivered
in cigarettes as you know I mean tobacco
companies put in a lot of work to figure
out the exact dose of nicotine that will
make you get that kind of feeling
that only lasts for a few minutes so you
want to do it again and again
um so we can talk about the and nicotine
you know
what becomes a a problem
in a specific Society with addiction is
not only based on the neurobiological
actions if we're talking still about
drugs or substances of that substance
it's heavily influenced by the
availability of the substance too but my
my little story is I smoke some
cigarettes in Paris I I I I learned why
people like to smoke it was very
satisfying to have a cigarette in a
Parisian Cafe it just you know it's very
interesting because the first few times
you inhale tobacco you get dizzy it's
kind of aversive and it's exactly what
you articulated despite that you want to
do it again so I I it was just a lot of
fun for me I enjoyed it and I was
disciplined you know at some point
whenever this was I came back the United
States I didn't smoke because I knew it
was bad for you but to this day
40 years later every time I go back to
Paris I get Cravings I actually just
want to get a pack of cigarettes I want
to
um have that feeling again of inhaling
the smoke but the point is of how
you know powerful these rewarding
experiences can be or reinforcing
experiences and for your audience
technically you know what I have been
taught by some of my psychology
colleagues is we use the term
reinforcing in a very behaviorally
defined way something is reinforcing is
if it the behavior that led to that
stimuli it makes you want to do that
behavior again rewarding means it
actually felt in quotes good
um that's an important decision
essentially can be different again as
you define by your friend who his I
forget I think it was cocaine cocaine
was highly reinforcing but it was not
necessarily enjoyable or rewarding and
isn't that fascinating I have a some
colleagues in the addiction field
um I one of them is retired now Kent
barrage and Terry Robinson they they
coin they distinguish between the terms
at wanting and liking and think about
that liking something means it's
something you like you enjoy
um wanting means you want it
but you don't necessarily like it or
enjoy it and that's a description of
your friends experience with cocaine
some of us have been in destructive
relationships where you want that
individual but you're not sure you
necessarily like that and sometimes
people will be in relationships where
they actively dislike the other person
which is a bit foreign of a concept to
me but well it's interesting this this
separation of reinforcing and rewarding
wanting and liking because
um one of the things that's very
prominent in 12-step programs is to
create rewards around abstaining from
the drug or behavior and I should
mention that programs like 12-step when
followed seem to have very high success
rates at least that's what Anna Lemke
tells me
um
that in some ways they are modifying the
wanting and liking they're splitting the
wanting and liking of you know alcohol
for instance creating a a liking of
sobriety more than the wanting of
alcohol for instance that's beautifully
put
um and I think that's right
um how that plays out in the neural
mechanisms that as a neuroscientist I'm
interested in it man that's a tough one
um
but I think that's why those programs
are pretty successful it's helping the
person
make those dissociations
um and I I don't know that much about
those programs because I have not seen
patients myself for whatever it's been
27 28 years but I think part of them are
to help that individual find as you both
other sources of liking and reward
getting some satisfaction satisfaction
and reward from the actual abstinence
being able to cognitively teach
themselves that I deserve a pat in the
back I deserve credit I feel good that I
did not take a drink at that party that
I did not use that substance again and
how that plays out in our brains is a
really tough one yeah those are um the
way you describe it is exactly right
those those programs are highly
reinforcing for abstinence behaviors
everything from the social connection
which we were are going to get to social
connection as we know
um to the way that people start to
conceptualize their addict self versus
other self it actually involves a
splitting of the self in interesting
ways
um as long as we're talking about Donuts
cigarettes alcohol cocaine
um I'm curious before we move to um a
bit more on neuroplasticity
is there anything that people ought to
know about how different substances
and behaviors that are addicting might
impact them
dopamine reward circuitry differently so
for instance we talked about cocaine as
having this very rapid onset big
increase in dopamine then a crash as we
know
um a certain pattern of kinetics as you
describe it
um the opioid crisis is is you know
incredibly serious problem right now uh
as is methamphetamine but it sounds like
methamphetamine functions a bit like
cocaine and in terms of its kinetics yes
so an opioid is a very different
chemical than Coke cocaine
um but it sounds like it impacts the
dopamine system is the dopaminergic
activity caused by opioids
responsible for the addictive properties
of opioids or do people also like the
feeling of being under opioids I
personally hate it coming out of surgery
like they gave me they gave me Vicodin
once
um and I hated it I'd rather have the
pain post-operative pain than take
something like
um you know Vicodin or a valium or
fentanyl or anything like that to me is
just completely aversive
um but I realized that there are many
millions of people that feel quite
differently
um it's a great question so I think all
the studies both in human beings and
pre-clinical animal models yes which
suggests that the con The Addictive
liability of opioids and
psychostimulants which are cocaine and
methamphetamine have the common
final action of causing massive release
of dopamine in this
Target of the dopamine neurons the
nucleus accumbens they do it if we want
to get a little scientifically technical
here via very different mechanisms so
cocaine and methamphetamine what the
drugs known as psychostimulants
actually bind to a protein in the brain
or a molecule in the brain that is
responsible for sucking up it's a vacuum
cleaner
sucking up the dopamine after it's been
released and cocaine prevents that
dopamine from being vacuumed up so the
cocaine hangs around longer meth not
only prevents the dopamine from being
vacuumed up it actually causes
the reverse it actually causes the
direct release of dopamine from what we
call nerve terminals from the site where
dopamine is released opioids work very
differently they actually primarily not
solely work where the dopamine neurons
live
and it's a little complicated it's not
that critical but they indirectly
it increase the activity within the
dopamine neurons themselves causing a
big massive bigger than normal release
of dopamine so that's one commonality
but anybody who has used these drugs you
read about these drugs the subjective
experience of the drugs are dramatically
different and that's because of the
actions they're having not only in the
reward circuitry but throughout the
brain so and it's interesting you talked
about Vicodin I've taken Vicodin because
I've had several knee surgeries and
things like you I didn't like it I've
I've gotten other opioids for pain
relief that
were great I mean they took they took
away a lot of pain after my ligament
repair
um
and that's a different question that
even when you're talking about opioids
all drugs are not CR they're not
identical fentanyl has a much big larger
addictive liability because of its
molecular properties and how it's
interacting
with the opioid system in our brains and
The receptors the actual proteins in the
brain that it interacts with but the
subjective experience of opioids I mean
it's interesting uh some people love it
that's you know if we go back in history
as you know there were the
um opium dens throughout
um Asia there were Wars about opioids
thing the the famous opioid Wars between
China and the United Kingdom I mean
showing you how powerful
um the availability of a substance like
an opioid can be so I'm going off in a
tangent no I apologize but commonality
is dopamine release in the accumbens but
it's a if you remember what a Venn
diagram is
all these drugs have some common actions
usually on directly or indirectly
causing the massive release of dopamine
in the incumbents but then they have
their own individual actions because
obviously when you take cocaine or
Methamphetamine it's a stimulator you're
you know people are grinding their teeth
they're hyped up
for most people opioids are the exact
opposite you I mean in opium dens from
the movies I watched and watching narcos
and all those TV shows you're often
you're lying down you're you're kind of
in almost a dream like state so very
different subjective experiences I'd
like to just take a brief break and
thank one of our sponsors which is
element element is an electrolyte drink
that has everything you need and nothing
you don't that means plenty of salt
sodium magnesium and potassium the
so-called electrolytes and no sugar now
salt magnesium and potassium are
critical to the function of all the
cells in your body in particular to the
function of your nerve cells also called
neurons and we now know that even slight
reductions in electrolyte concentrations
or dehydration of the body can lead to
deficits and cognitive and physical
performance element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of 1
000 milligrams that's one gram of sodium
200 milligrams of potassium and 60
milligrams of magnesium I typically
drink element first thing in the morning
when I wake up in order to hydrate my
body and make sure I have enough
electrolytes and while I do any kind of
physical training and after physical
training as well especially if I've been
sweating a lot and certainly I drink
element in my water when I'm in the
sauna and after going in the sauna
because that causes quite a lot of
sweating if you'd like to try element
you can go to drink element that's
lmnt.com huberman to claim a free
element sample pack with your purchase
again that's drinkelement lmnt.com
huberman yeah I had an experience with
uh opioid recently uh not voluntarily
over the Christmas holiday we went to
visit friends and before going to sleep
I wanted some tea and I asked if they
had any non-caffeinated tea so they gave
me this tea and and that night I had the
most bizarre dreams I've ever had and I
slept for 14 hours the next morning I
was like what was that tea and I felt
off in the morning and and I went it was
actually a blue lotus flower tea that is
actually illegal in the United States
but it is sold and it has morphine like
um compounds in it
um and I am one of those people that's
very susceptible to even low doses of
any kind of Novel drug you know so so
interesting have you ever taken cough
syrup with dextromethorphan no I avoid
that stuff well I you know I have if I
can I have a tendency when I get a cold
like it gets into my lungs I cough a lot
and I think this has been reported this
is my anecdotal experience I'm
confirming what you said Dexter
methorphan
is a different sort of opioid and
actually some people develop a problem
with it for me it gives me really
bizarre dreams really similar to what
you were it was very unusual and that's
a whole different conversation about
what makes us dream and what the what
are the meaning of dreams fascinating
and I hope you covered maybe you've
covered that we have not yet but we are
intending to do a whole series on
sleeping dreams
I started out in sleep research so I
have a fondness for it drug research and
sleep research have a long history of
overlap with Alan Hobson's work on I
worked with Alan Hobson okay by the way
folks if you're interested in the
relationship between uh hallucinations
and dreaming Alan Hobson is a good name
to start your uh your rabbit 19 Rabbit
Hole 19 oh my God I'm dating myself 19.
oh 70 I can't remember it was 76 or 77 I
worked with Alan Hobson as an
undergraduate at Harvard yeah no as an
undergraduate at Harvard he was at
Harvard Medical School yeah right
amazing I love his writing and I learned
a lot from it he's really ahead of his
time yes he was yeah I will get it
nobody would anybody who knows me won't
believe this but I back then I was a
very shy insecure you know 20 year old
would not have guessed who oh
I and even in medical school I I
literally was not confident of my
opinions at all I was very shy was
thought all of the ideas I had must be
obvious and I should never say them out
loud do you mind if I ask you since you
raised this I think it's really
important I mean you you have this
incredible uh career track record
um I you know you're adored by your
colleagues you're highly respected
You've Won just about every award there
is to win in Neuroscience so was there
something in particular that
um like was it an overnight thing where
one day you woke up and thought you know
I actually believe in myself but if you
wouldn't mind sharing that because I
think before we get back into some of
the the science I you know this science
is a human endeavor and most people
listening are probably not scientists
but I think everybody deals with these
issues of of self-doubt and
people appear to have varying levels of
confidence but uh what what happened uh
so thank you for asking
um
no for me it was a very gradual process
and I'm not as an undergraduate as a
medical student even as a postdoc yeah I
was very unsure of my ideas of my
intellectual abilities of whether
what I was thinking was really you know
worthwhile so it was a very gradual
process I think it the increase in my
confidence I think began when I was a
postdoc which is a training period after
you've received a PhD or an MD where you
get additional research training and I
worked with a guy named Roger Nichol at
UCSF and Roger was a very for
intellectually intense very forceful
individual and I got involved in a field
where I mean people a little bit of a
tangent you're you're your listeners may
think that scientists are these geeky
individuals wearing white coats with no
passion or emotion and nothing could be
further from the truth the most
successful scientists I know are pretty
passionate and pretty intense about what
what they're working on and driven
I mean then this is a gross
generalization so anyhow during my
postdoc I started getting involved in a
topic where there were vigorous
arguments about
phenomenology we were studying so I had
to develop a tougher and thicker skin I
had to be able to argue my side of of
the hypotheses we were generating so it
started developing as a postdoc and then
it slowly evolved as an assistant
professor and for your listeners who
don't know I don't like to admit this
but I'm in my late 60s I've been running
my own lab for almost 40 years
um so I have been so gradually as an
assistant professor I realized hey I can
do this I can do science I can write
papers that my colleagues seem to be
interested in and then gradually you
know over then the next 10 20 30 years
I gained more and more confidence I so
for me it was just very gradual
um buildup of many different experiences
where I developed some confidence that
you know not all of my ideas are great
of course they're not but
it's okay to voice my opinion it's okay
to State my ideas and why I believe this
and why I don't believe that so that was
my experience thank you for sharing that
because I think uh you know people
struggle with that very issue and um
clearly showing up again and again over
a long period of time is helpful but as
you said you know learning to trust
one's ideas just a brief anecdote when I
was coming up in Neuroscience a few
years behind you
um 20 years behind me not two minutes
not too many I mean decades but um but I
recall the incredible number of
high-profile papers on neuroplasticity
and long-term potentiation long-term
depression these are terms related to
the modification of synapses
um that Rob malenka and Roger Nicole
pioneered a big segment to that work and
yes I remember seeing your names on
papers and I thought Roger worked for
you yeah sorry Roger I love it I'd love
to hear that
and only later did I learn that you were
uh his post-docs and then and then we
collaborated as you became peers very
quickly very quickly yeah so you've had
a and Roger you know I Roger's wonderful
I did have the confidence even as a
postdoc
and he actually even as a grad student
even though I was a little insecure
about my ideas I wanted to be treated as
an equal that's the one thing I did have
I never felt that I was working for
somebody else I always felt that I was
working for myself and that we were
colleagues even though my mentors or my
who had more experience and I could
learn from them but I like that you're
working for yourself even though you
have mentors I think there's some
there's some real gems in what you just
described so thank you for sure taking
the time to do that sure I'd like to
discuss one aspect of reward circuitry
that I don't think most people think
about right it's fairly straightforward
I know days I I like to think more
people know what dopamine is and
understand it thanks to your work and
Anna's work and some discussions have
taken place on our podcast other
podcasts but
you know all too often we think dopamine
reward wanting liking drugs okay all of
that is great but what about the truly
adaptive stuff right because it's it's
um easy to fall into a discussion around
dopamine of you know the things that are
bad for us but what I'm thinking about
here is social interaction yeah
um clearly we are a social species and a
lot of your work in the last
um decade and a half or so has focused
on the relationship between the reward
circuitry which you beautifully
described for us and
social interaction and connection and
where I'm going with this is ultimately
this has huge implications for
autism and autism spectrum disorders I
don't know if nowadays is it okay you're
not supposed to call autism a disease is
that right you hear about neurotypical
and neuroatypical but is but I have
friends who have children who are
severely autistic and um I don't know
many parents who would elect to have a
severely autistic kid and so those
people often will talk about it as
autism or a child having autism so first
of all before we get into the social
piece maybe because I just tabled it
what it how are we supposed to talk
about autism nowadays I I I am very
interested in the pathophysiology of
what the medical profession terms autism
spectrum disorder as you pointed out
the individuals living with an Autism
Spectrum Disorder are quite
heterogeneous and it it can range from
individuals with severe intellectual
impairments and quite severe impairments
in social interactions impairments and
sensory processing impairments and lots
of different aspects of our behaviors
that are important and I think nobody
would say would argue those individuals
on the severe Spectrum do not have some
sort of
in quotes disorder the issue we have to
be sensitive to is it's it's a
heterogeneous disorder like many brain
issues that psychiatrists deal with like
depression we all
um like obsessive-compulsive disorder
like various anxiety disorders it's
always on a Continuum and a spectrum so
for autism spectrum disorder there are
individuals who are high functioning who
one could argue have a different style
of interacting socially may have a
different way of processing Sentry
information but who have who would
prefer not to be viewed as having an
illness but rather would be viewed as
having a different style of living and
interaction and I think we need to
respect that so the challenge is again
not oversimplifying a complex
heterogeneous
[Music]
disorder
and both being respectful of the people
who don't want to be defined as having a
Neuropsychiatric or brain disorder while
equally being respectful of people like
your friends with severely impaired
children who deserve help who deserve
research and it's a tough one because my
understanding from to be honest just
reading articles in the lay press and
going to websites from organizations
that philanthropically support research
related to autism within that community
of individuals who are not researchers
but who are have family members or are
themselves dealing with some degree of
autism spectrum disorder there's
disagreements about how to what
terminology to use how to deal with them
and it's complicated I think we just
have to respect everybody and if you're
interacting with individuals you know I
think it's appropriate what do you
prefer I do know as a medical
professional there and especially when
you're dealing with children there are
children who need help and I I we're not
doing them a service by saying they
don't have an issue that we should be
helping them with and working on so I
hope that answers your question
beautiful I think it beautifully answers
it and encompasses all sides um so that
we can move forward and I think we'll so
as we use the term uh autism or children
or people with autism
um that's what we're referring to I
think people are very sensitive
especially those
individuals who are neuroatypical who
previously might be diagnosed as autism
spectrum disorder but would prefer to
not be labeled as having a brain illness
that that's fine
um it's kind of once you are an adult
you can make that decision for yourself
we certainly have colleagues at Stanford
and elsewhere who at least by my
non-clinical assessments sometimes
somewhere on that spectrum and again
it's a Continuum just like you know the
experience of depression is a Continuum
but all right but as with depression you
wouldn't love a child or an adult any
less because they have depression nor
would you love a child or adult any less
because of uh expression of some autism
I know the point people don't you know
and so we we have been we are being
trained in the medical profession to be
very
for you know in our society is going
this way too very careful with the terms
we use and the labeling of individuals
um so yeah you know I've been taught you
can say individuals living with an
Autism Spectrum Disorder
um some people don't like using a term
oh that individual is autistic because
that has some can have some
I don't want to say derogatory meaning
but some labeling kind of but you know
sometimes this gets out of control too
as we both know well for sake of fluid
conversation we will do our best but
um we will acknowledge from the outset
that we are well-meaning but far from
perfect and how we'll handle this well
well put so in thinking about social
interactions and leaving aside anything
related to autism for the moment
it appears that the circuits in the
brain that mediate the desire to spend
time with others of the same species
maybe even with other species like a dog
um are fairly hardwired but modifiable
they we were born with the capacity to
build them up
and that social behavior is highly
rewarded is it rewarded through the
dopamine system and what if any
involvement is there of the serotonergic
system and we haven't talked about
serotonin yet but I'd love to bring up
serotonin at this point maybe you could
educate us a little bit about serotonin
because
um gosh if dopamine is fascinating
serotonin is at least as incredible
um yeah great question so I think for me
the easiest way for me to answer it is
actually just tell you
my research history and how a lab like
mine at Stanford that at one point was
studying
what I what you and I would call fairly
hardcore molecular mechanisms of
neuroplasticity how to
connections between nerve cells change
and what molecules are changing and
pretty hardcore molecular stuff how did
I end up studying social behaviors in
mice and what I hope we'll end up
talking about even developing behavioral
models of what I will Define as empathy
in mice the answer is very simple my lab
was working on
the roles of classic dopamine rewards
circuitry and how it changes in models
of addiction we haven't talked about
depression models of depression because
just intuitively hopefully your
listeners can understand if one
component of depression is what we call
anhedonia the inability to experience
reward you know eating a donut is no
longer satisfying having sex is no
longer that much fun which is a
component of depression if there's a
mechanism in the brain that tells you
something is rewarding by definition
that's not functioning normally in
severe depression so we were doing
models of depression to figure out how
the dopamine reward circuitry was
changing as were many other labs we were
studying addiction those were the
obvious ones and I mean it might be
entertaining to do to your audience to
learn how academic scientists think I
was thinking those are fascinating
topics they're pretty competitive
lots of other labs were working on it
and I started thinking what other
experiences might be modifying the
reward circuitry I actually made some
attempts to look at feeding Behavior but
I don't want to I mean we actually never
pursued that for a variety of reasons
and that's obviously important because
of there is an obesity
epidemic in this country and we can talk
about how the reward circuitry and some
of the things we've learned from our
studies of addiction May
be helpful to understanding obesity but
back to social interaction I started
thinking well for most of us uh
what I call a pro-social
non-sexual experience is highly
reinforcing Andrew you're a pretty
social guy I'm a pretty social guy most
of the time I'd rather go to a movie a
sporting event a dinner with friends
um it's you know actually for me the
most meaningful component of my life
other than spending time with my
children is spending time with my close
friends and I started thinking well why
is that why do I have such a good time
going to a ball game with my best friend
or going out to dinner with another
couple and interacting it's because well
it's highly reinforcing and if it's
highly reinforcing it must involve the
reward circuitry and then I started
thinking evolutionarily it makes a lot
of sense because if you are part of a
social species there's a lot of
evolutionarily
a lot of advantages
for your survival to be hanging out with
other members of your species in a
non-aggressive way it can increase your
likelihood to find a mate and reproduce
it can protect you from predators I mean
that's why any of your listeners who
ever watch you know Wildlife shows or
National Geographic shows there's a
reason all these animals hang out
together it's for protection from
predators so there are all these reasons
so
about whenever it was 13 or 14 years ago
my lab decided to start looking at how
the reward circuitry may play a role in
what I am going to call positive
pro-social
non-aggressive interactions another word
we use is just sociability
and for a variety of reasons that back
then this is God this is at least 13
years ago maybe 15 years ago a postdoc
joined my lab named Gould Dolan she's
now a professor at Johns Hopkins
um and she had an interest in oxytocin
um
and as your listeners know
oxytocin is this evolutionarily
conserved neuropeptide that's very
important for parturition the having a
baby born from milk being produced and
it's gotten a lot of attention as a
potential
love neuropeptide is something that is
released in our brains
during a positive social interaction
there's a well-known researcher in
social behavior and bonding research
called Larry young and he did some very
important now somewhat classic work
studying a species called the vole in
particular the Prairieville and Prairie
voles are a species where they mate for
life it's called pair bonding so one
bowl will find another vole they
basically get married they have kids and
they're they hang out together for the
rest of their life no divorces
divorce rate and what Larry elegantly
showed
um in part in early days in
collaboration with a guy named Tom Insel
who is a famous academic psychiatrist
they showed that oxytocin action within
the nucleus accumbens within this reward
circuitry was required and really
important for this monogamous pair
bonding having said that there was just
a paper that called into question that
but that's but there's 30 years of
research prior to that and I'm glad you
brought that up because uh we'll keep
this contemporary and the the reality is
that that recent paper got a lot of
attention yeah maybe oxytocin isn't
playing as prominental and fair bonding
as people have thought and yet folks uh
that could be true we have to be
scientific about this and be open-minded
but there's you know three decades of
work that that speaks to the contrary so
I think we want to be a little we want
to weigh the evidence yeah exactly and
again the the investigators who
presented the work saying oxytocin may
not be as important there are
limitations to the manipulations they
did which they would agree with so I'm
just telling you so
was a postdoc in my lab and we decided
we formulated a project to look at the
actions of oxytocin in the nucleus
accumbens in mice and the reason we
study mice is you they're what are known
as a genetic genetically tractable
organism we have all sorts of really
cool and sophisticated tricks we can do
to probe brain circuitry the actions of
neuromodulators like dopamine and
serotonin and oxytocin
in ways that we can't do in other
species and I'm going to get back to
dopamine in a second and what we found
was that oxytocin action in the nucleus
accumbens was indeed important for
promoting sociability probably for
promoting the reinforcing
component of a social interaction and
that surprised us you know it was like
wow it's it's oxytocin seems to be
causing
enhancing the release of serotonin in
the nucleus accumbens and that will I'm
perhaps we'll get to this that led me
off on a whole series of experiments
trying to figure out how serotonin Works
studying this drug we may talk about
called MDMA which is ecstasy or Molly
which actually causes release of
Serotonin so we did that work and that
God is working in serotonin
simultaneously there were some other
papers reporting that dopamine release
in the incumbents that dopamine is
released in the incumbens during a
social interaction a positive
non-aggressive social interaction truth
be told it may also be released
during an aggressive interaction some
people like to fight some people like to
fight and the difference here is the
dopamine release and its role in social
interactions it's not specific only for
social interaction as we have talked
about but nevertheless that led my lab
and other labs to do a series of papers
I'm talking about the field now showing
that
and I'm giving you a lot of information
here so
how might dopamine release happen during
a non-aggressive social interaction it
turns out that oxytocin is not only
released in the nucleus accumbens it's
released in the home of the dopamine
neurons in the VTA
so my lab in another lab from
Northwestern showed that oxytocin can
actually modulate dopamine neuron
activity in the ventral tegmental area
so I hope I'm making sense here I don't
want to get too technical no I think it
just shows how the you know we discuss
these neuromodulators like dopamine I
just brought in oxytocin we're going to
talk about serotonin in a second
unfortunately for your listeners they
don't work in isolation they commun they
influence each other in ways that I
think it's important for us to
understand and elucidate
that is not too much technical detail um
and I think it's wonderfully rich with
areas for us to discuss and I'm so very
glad that you brought up that neither
dopamine nor serotonin or oxytocin work
in isolation because all too often and
admittedly sometimes even on my podcast
I'll talk about these things in
isolation as a way to try and simplify
them a bit but there's just no way that
the brain works that way you know for
instance turning on dopamine and turning
off serotonin it's a waiting of of
inputs and I think that serotonin
perhaps I should frame it this way just
as often as dopamine is framed as this
reward molecule and pleasure and
dopamine hits all too often I think in
the popular press
serotonin is discussed in oxytocin 2 for
that matter as this kind of warm feel
good everything's mellow
um you know not really associated with a
reward and reinforcement and uh of
course it's not that simple so when it
comes to social interactions it sounds
like oxytocin and serotonin are playing
a prominent role also in the accumbens
um and that dopamine is is activated too
do I have that right okay so um I don't
want to take us too far down the rabbit
hole of neural circuit function but that
to me
um makes at least a brief discussion
about the nucleus accumbens itself
interestingly okay so I'm thinking
nucleus I know that means a pile of
neurons an aggregation of neurons it's
talking to this ventral striatum so we
got a function part of the ventral
strion part of that it's a subdivision
excuse me yeah I misspoke
um yeah it's part of the ventral
striatum and it's
um and the neurons there can be active
and communicate with other brain areas
but we're talking about a lot of nuance
of function oh man so so I'm not I'm
smiling I don't know if your audience is
just see me smile because it's so I I
sometimes go to bed feeling it's so
complicated oh my gosh it is and yet
could we say that within the nucleus
accumbens there are neurons that are
acting as
accelerators and breaks
um I mean is there a simple analogy that
perhaps while not exhaustive can still
be true because that's always the goal
on this podcast there's no way you can
be exhaustive but we want to be as
accurate as possible so a very
influential hypothesis which has guided
my thinking and again the trick I mean
you know you have done a wonderful job
of communicating complex scientific
topics
to your podcast audience and I
congratulate you on that
um and it's really it's a really
important role
um
but as you know it's always more
complicated than we wanted to be as
scientist especially when you're dealing
with brain
activity issues and how the brain
mediates all its amazing functions
um so historically we have thought about
the nucleus accumbens and other
components of this ventral striatal
brain area as
primarily being composed of two
different cell types and as you pointed
out one being sort of an accelerator
something that promotes certain
behaviors and then the other cell type
somewhat being a break saying don't do
that behavior don't perform that motor
action
and
it it is true that there are these
different cell types it is true that
they are modulated
by these modulators like dopamine and
serotonin in different ways and that
simplistic hypothesis or heuristic we
call it has been very useful in making
models about how the accumbens does all
its wonderful things what I'm leading up
to is it's it unfortunately it's a
little more complicated but yes it's
there are two different cell types and
at least for your audience we can think
about dopamine driving the activity of
one promoting certain behaviors and
inhibiting the activity of the other
cell type and being a sort of break on
certain behaviors as long as you and I
as scientists appreciate it's not quite
that simple it's a little more
complicated so using that as a framework
to think about social behavior as you
said you know pro-social non-aggressive
non-sexual interactions involve the
choice of a lot of behaviors but also
the suppression of a lot of behaviors
and um and so maybe you're starting to
sense what I'm doing here I'm I I think
for people to understand how a single
structure like the accumbens could
mediate social interaction and reward it
it sounds like it's doing is rewarding a
certain category or and catalog of
Behavioral options and punishing or at
least reducing the probability of the
occurrence of other behavioral actions
because when I go to dinner with friends
if I know them really well yeah I might
hug them I might even say something
mildly inappropriate if I know the
context to be safe right but at a dinner
interview or a discussion with somebody
you know I barely know I might watch my
words a little bit more
um for instance and I think the
accumbens and its Associated Circle I
love the way you just put that
probabilities it's my probability of
having this behavior in a certain
context is increase my Pro the
probabilities of not doing certain
behaviors and I think there's little
doubt that this brain area called the
nucleus accumbens and all of its
Associated circuitry play a very
important role in what behaviors you
choose to do pursue play a very
important role in these making the
decision and Performing these pro-social
non-aggressive non-sexual interactions I
actually also think it plays a role in
empathy in leading you there I want to
have a discussion about that please
again
as a mechanistically driven
neuroscientist what is frustrating for
me is I I know a lot of the connections
it's making and the other brain areas
it's communicating with but I can't give
you a coherent
hypothesis or diagram of how it all
happens yes you know yeah yeah you're
still going what I can say is even at
our current level of understanding
it is leading to novel hypotheses that
are allowing the develop you know
perhaps you know if we bring it back to
autism that are allowing the development
of Novel at the moment
pharmacologic Therapeutics that might be
helpful for people who
are not having normal pro-social
interactions and would like to have them
would like to be able to fun function in
that domain in a more adaptive and
productive and meaningful way and that's
the important of the importance in my
view of the kind of mechanistic work my
lab and many other labs around the
country are doing even if we don't have
a detailed
understanding of how it's all happening
we can identify drugs and druggable
targets or even behavioral interventions
that might actually help people
for for example suffering from autism
spectrum disorder
of the sort that they actually want and
need
interact need therapeutic help I think
looking at the social connection
circuitry through the lens of autism is
going to be very interesting for us to
do I do have a question about what is
being selected for in rewarding social
interactions because obviously
um we are living in a time where
you know we don't have to aggregate in
groups necessarily to protect ourselves
physically
um it helps in certain ways um in
certain circumstances but
certainly to support ourselves and each
other emotionally you know having people
that we can call on when we're not
feeling so well that we can look to for
resources and that they can look to us
um but when we go out to dinner with
friends or we go to a ball game with
friends or we interact with friends I'm
very familiar with the feeling of like
well that felt really good it just felt
good it gives me energy it actually
gives me energy to go back and do other
things like spend four days alone with a
bunch of papers and lectures preparing
for a podcast which I also really enjoy
um but when I do that when I go out to
dinner with friends or see friends I'm
not thinking about buffering myself
against loneliness when I do it I just
like the interaction so
um
what sorts of uh um evolutionary
hypotheses can we come up with as to why
the human brain is so tuned for these
social interactions why it's rewarded by
not just one dopamine but also serotonin
serotonin and oxygen three prominent
neuromodulatory uh chemicals in the
brain are devoted at one site in the
brain and others that it's connected to
of course but to making sure that we do
this as often as possible without giving
up the rest of our lives well I mean I
again I think the answer I'm going to be
able to give I hope it's not tried and
it may be a little bit obvious is
and it it in some ways it's it's it's
analogous to
why drugs of abuse and addiction are
also a problem is that
the circuitry that is telling us a
pro-social
positive interaction is so highly
reinforcing evolved over you know
millions of years or hundreds of
thousands of years whatever that is and
I the only hypothesis I can come up with
and Andrew you may be able to come up
with better ones is what I alluded to
earlier is that it was very adaptive
when we were more primitive organisms
never mind non-human primates but when
we were whatever we were
to be a social species
um for basically primarily two reasons
for Reproductive purposes it increased
your likelihood of reproducing if you
were hanging out with other members of
your species in a non-aggressive way and
for protection against predators and
there may be other reasons
um probably child rearing too oh yeah in
your absence you want trusted friends
that can watch your offspring thank you
very good point so the circuits the
modulators we use that evolved over
Millennia and as you pointed out
um
you know eventually I mean depending on
the society in which you live you didn't
need those social interactions for
protection against predators
um although you know if we look at our
world now one can make arguments both
ways if you're in a war zone is it
better to be off by yourself is it
better to be with a group of people
um but so they the mechanisms evolved
for one purpose and they don't just
disappear because there's no
disadvantage to having this mechanism
that tells us of social interaction is
reinforcing and I would still argue
there's benefit for Reproductive
purposes you can't have kids if you're
by yourself all the time well this is
actually I think it's impossible right
at least currently and you can't find a
partner with whom to have kids if you're
socially isolated or it makes it much
harder so I hope I'm answering your
question I think
um
and then and then as you pointed out
the you know for many of us there's a
lot of positive aspects to having
friendships and hanging out with your
friends emotional support emotional
buffering and feeling connected they're
feeling connected feeling connected I'm
uh and later we'll talk about
psychedelics but yeah yeah this notion
of feeling connected
um has a lot to do with buffering
loneliness when we are alone the
memories and the and the energy for lack
of a better word
um that we feel in recalling Social
experiences and anticipating social
experiences is really powerful you
mentioned
um that you know that people can't have
children if they spend all their time
alone it's actually I realize you're not
on social media and more power to you
but this is actually a prominent
discussion on social media you know
there's an entire culture of young
people in particular young men these
days who at least from what I understand
in the the research literature about
this are socially isolated spending all
their Time online maybe not even on
social media but are spending a lot of
time online video games hiding in
electronic landscapes
digital Landscapes
um and concern about mental health
issues there uh Etc uh concern about
porn overuse and addiction there Etc but
social media itself is an incredible
phenomenon to consider in light of
everything we're talking about
um
I can't say even though I am on social
all social media platforms
um and I you know quite active there I
can't say that I've ever been on social
media and experienced the kind of
delight and thrill and persistent energy
uh increase that I experience with
in-person interaction and yet social
media I have to assume is capitalizing
on some of the same reward mechanisms in
presumably the nucleus accumbens so um
are there any data I realize this is a
hard experiment to do in mice may be
impossible are there any data that
you're aware of that
um that shows that social media
has a high addictive liability or do we
even need an experiment
I I'm not sure we need an experiment I
think it clearly does
um I agree with the point you're making
although
your podcast audience probably doesn't
know who I am I am in my late 60s I grew
up well they know who you are now I grew
up before
computers before cell phones
um so I still am a believer perhaps in
an old-fashioned way that physical
interpersonal reactions are really
important obviously there are
advantages to being able to interact
over social media and I I mean for all
sorts of reasons there's a lot of
positive and good from that but back to
your question can we get addicted I I
can't speak to social media I can speak
an Anna Lemke you know I think can is
much more
able to eloquently describe the issues
around you I can just talk from my own
experience that
my cell phone is
um and chat you know this isn't social
media but checking my email messages
checking my texting my text messages
has a for me has a compulsive addictive
equality it's like a lever press for a
mouse and it I and part of that is my
own personality part of that is
the immediate feedback so
you get from a social media post from
seeing your name mentioned getting a
message from one of your friends sure
you know I like getting messages from my
friends it means they're thinking about
me it means I'm part of their world I
have no doubt it's activating my reward
circuitry not nearly to the degree that
a hit of cocaine or an opioid would do
um so
I I don't know what else to say about it
I uh
I I think
as a society we we have to be aware of
these issues and it's really com
complicated how we manage especially you
know once you're an adult you make your
own decisions for better or worse but
you know it's a huge issue obviously for
anybody who has children or is planning
to have children and adults on social
media I mean I see lots of accounts of
people that are 18 and older who they
spend a lot of time on there and and I'm
not necessarily saying that's a bad
thing a lot of people have entire
careers that exist on social media it
just seems to me that
um Instagram Facebook LinkedIn Twitter
have capitalized on this hardwired
circuitry app the release of ox I mean
to make it really reductionist the
release of Serotonin dopamine and
oxytocin by virtue of someone saying
something to us maybe not even a
positive thing maybe it's a a negative
thing as you said they're thinking of us
there's something about being recognized
by others and maybe this is a good seg
we're heading towards empathy here a
discussion about empathy I I think
that's very well put it is capitalizing
on these more primitive neurobiological
mechanisms that evolved
for purposes of reproduction and
survival I think that's
certainly has to be the case uh and I
think it's important I mean thank you
for bringing that up for
us as a society to be at least aware of
this and it doesn't mean it's like many
things it's not all good it's not all
bad it has there are positive uses of
social media I can see but you know
mostly we read about the the dangers of
it we read about these kids who are
socially isolated who make bad decisions
based on what they're seeing with social
media
um but anyhow back to the neuro
Neuroscience you're absolutely correct
um and capitalizing on these mechanisms
that evolved for physical interpersonal
react interactions because our Evolution
didn't anticipate it right just as
pornography is capitalizing on the
sexual arousal reward circuit Associated
rewards no question about it right and
yeah just as the gambling industry does
I mean as you know that you know the
Vegas casinos
have full-time people developing
algorithms for
how frequently should a slot machine pay
off what you know what's the perfect
amount of payoff to keep
certain individuals coming back so
pernicious yeah someone uh you could
tell I've been spending a lot of time
around addicts and former addicts I've
been researching some some things for
the podcast
um and a gambling addict uh told me
something interesting they said you know
the the real Stinger with being a
gambling addict is that the next time
really could change everything whereas
no alcoholic says that that the next
drink could change everything for the
better or you know the the cocaine
addict doesn't think oh you know the
next line of cocaine could could make
all of life better now and forever
whereas the gambling addict actually
holds in mind the infinitesimally small
and yet real potential that the next
time really could wipe out their debt
and prep perhaps and yet we know they
would lose that too right whatever
winnings and casinos are fully aware of
this I have been told by friends who
know they have they employ you know
full-time
quantitative you know for lack of better
term well I I was going to say computer
geek I don't mean to that the um
I would be amazed if they don't have
neuroscientists who have expertise in
what's called neuro economics or
behavioral economics
um yeah I I I I'm 95 sure that has to be
the case I occasionally sit down to the
roulette table because I just yeah so
massive and easy and not long ago
actually I had the experience of winning
uh fairly not a large sum but but a
meaningful sum of money and I'll tell
you my sole Mission at that point was to
get up and go back to my room and not
stop at another table and I confess I
pulled one brief stop at another table
played one hand and then and lost it and
then just got back to my room as quickly
as possible and then left Las Vegas as
quickly as possible yeah gambling is but
they'll probably get me the next time
yeah gambling is a you know again it all
gets back to this reward circuitry and
the um
intermittently intermittent rewards are
very very powerful well and you
mentioned earlier that the the reward
system is powerfully tuned to remember
what were the behaviors that led up to
the rewarding experience and and nobody
nobody ever won on the at the roulette
or craps table or poker table
um by getting up and leaving yeah yeah
right exactly so I guess my brain was
just thinking well how did I win I won
by sitting down and putting chips on the
table not by going back to my room
exactly exactly and yet I have you know
a fair number of degrees and I'd like to
think my prefrontal cortex is working
and yet it was still challenging in that
moment gambling is really interesting I
mean yeah another
human activity that's quite complicated
it can be enjoyable or it can be
incredibly damaging yeah and now people
are going to think I was that gambling
addicted but I swear I'm not fortunately
I feel very blessed that that's not my
addiction
um I'd like to talk about empathy and
use that as a framework for eventually
returning to our discussion of autism
but
um you have this perhaps long-standing
interest but recent research interest in
empathy tell me about this work I'm not
familiar with it okay so I am gonna I'm
gonna I hope it's okay Dragon the some
work I've done on this drug called MDMA
because it is related
um so we were working on in my lab
social behaviors positive pro-social
behaviors
um that stimulated me to start thinking
about what are components of a positive
pro-social non-aggressive interaction
um
I
a a a
common key component of that is having
some empathy and compassion for the
individuals you're hanging out with and
it is the topic I've been interested in
for many many decades I was once a
psychiatrist
um and to get on my whatever the word is
hobby horse
I look at the world today I try to be
optimistic again I am a child of the 60s
and 70s when I look at the world and I
actually just did a trip to Israel to
give a series of lectures and I look at
the israeli-palestinian conflict what
always enters my mind is I've felt this
way for decades is what is more
important for the survival of the human
species than empathy and compassion then
actually being able to look at another
human being even if they look different
than you even if they have a different
belief system than you what is more
important than actually understanding
that 98 percent of your life is very is
is is very similar you know if you have
some differences in how you look and the
beliefs you have but there's so much in
common so what's more important than
understanding that when another person
is suffering they're suffering it's the
same as you're suffering we um and
having compassion for somebody so I
started thinking what is more important
and I'm not a politician as you know
Andrew I have no social media presence I
figured the only way I might be able to
contribute
to
efforts that might help you the human
species enhance empathy and compassion
is by studying the neurobiological
underpinnings of it and I didn't realize
I might be able to do that until I
started studying sociability or
pro-social behaviors in mice and then
I was
able to have a young woman scientist and
I want to give her credit Monique Smith
you might want to have Monique on your
podcast she's a she's a Dynamo she's now
an assistant professor at UCSD
um and Monique introduced me to a series
of Behavioral essays
that I like to use that I like to use
the phrase they are measurements they
are behavioral antecedents of empathy
because
in the world of psychologists and people
who use the term empathy it has a lot of
different meanings to different people
I'm using it basically to mean one
member of a species
manifests some behavior that indicates
it is being influenced by the emotional
state or what we call the effective
State effective with an a of another
member of that species in its immediate
environment
um and it for human interactions I just
think of you know any of we were talking
about friendships any of us who have
watch a close friend suffer it's hard
you want to do anything you can to help
them that's empathy a mother with their
child a good mother hopefully you know
when you have a kid who is sick there's
nothing worse as a parent you just want
to take that pain and suffering away
that's how I'm defining empathy so it's
my belief that like any complex human
behavior there are evolutionary
reasons why that has been adaptive and
important and maintained and if it's
evolutionarily
evolved there are ways of studying it in
more primitive organisms like mice so
I'll tell you some of the behavioral
assays we're doing one is and I I get a
kick out of this
um because it's it's pretty new for me
so one assay and we published a paper in
a journal called science about this
which is if you take one Mouse
and in a ethical way you put it in pain
you make its hind paw one of its paws
one of its feet hurt a modest amount and
you take another mouse and you let that
what's known as the bystander Mouse just
hang out with the mouse that's in pain
for one hour just one hour the bystander
Mouse who has experienced no physical
injury whatsoever will manifest
behaviors indicating it is now in pain
and it lasts maybe four to twenty hours
but think about that a mouse just hang a
mouse that is normal hanging out with
another mouse in pain starts feeling and
pain itself and the and the mice are
able to see one another and hear one
another good point so you're getting to
how is that communication happening and
a lot more work needs to be done on it
um Monique and her previous colleagues
and others
one component of it is probably an
olfactory cue or what we call a
pheromone is secreting probably probably
because you can take betting from mice
and pain and expose the bystander mice
so that's one thing and I had never
heard of these behavioral assays we
developed our and this is pretty cool
and then I'll tell you two others and
then I'll tell you how it connects to
reward circuitry
um
we developed a novel assay which is the
social transfer of Pain Relief pain
relief is called analgesia and I thought
this was pretty cool so you take
and this is in this paper that was
published in science a year ago you take
two mice and they're both in pain
modest pain I don't want your listeners
to get upset we are not hurting these
mice too badly and it is a tricky issue
is it you know is it okay to put a mouse
in pain so you can the goal is to
develop better treatments for human
beings in pain obviously
um so you have two mice in modest pain
you give one mice mouse morphine so it's
now analgesic it is no longer
experiencing pain you take another mouse
that's in pain and you just let it hang
out with the mouse that is no longer in
pain and the mouse that is in pain will
show behaviors indicating it it is
experiencing analgesia it is no longer
in as much pain now think about that and
there's actually evidence from Human
studies that I can't speak to in any
comprehensive way where I mean it's
called social buffering of pain if you
are I mean to be honest I've been having
some neck pain just because I'm an old
guy and I woke up on the wrong side of
the bed and if I'm by myself I focus on
that pain and it bothers me more if I'm
in a social socially engaged I think
it's not only that I'm not paying as
much attention to the pain but I think
there's actually some relief from what's
known as the social buffering of pain so
well I'm no hippie but I actually think
that
um all species including humans are
secreting molecules mainly odorants that
are perhaps even acting directly as as
analgesics and I can make that statement
with without ordering too much that
people think I'm completely crazy
because we had a gnome Sobel on the
podcast from the wise men who shared
with us you know not one not two but at
least a dozen ways in which humans are
making molecules typically odors and
communicating those to one another to
powerfully impact their testosterone
levels their vasopressin levels their
immune molecules you know and and of
course gnome works on old-fashioned so
he's going to be biased toward that
system but that's just one slice of the
sensory array I mean what about the the
way that somebody can look at us in a
way that makes us feel good on a normal
day well when we're in pain just even
the touch to a shoulder can mean a lot
yeah I remember going to meetings when I
was a early neuroscientist and I would
probably at that point of
um you know not been the type to just
walk up and say hello to you because I
wasn't in your field and you're this
luminary and stuff but but I remember as
I started I'm a good guy you are very
very good
um I always say hi to everybody I know
you are and that that statement was a
reflection on it I'm not a reflection on
you but as I Advanced through my career
what I found was you know you'd give a
talk or something and someone in your
field more senior to you who you
respected uh would give a nod or
something those nods mean a lot
absolutely those nods could carry you a
long distance I mean obviously we want
to be intrinsically driven to do the
work we do but but this social
communication social species I think
there's a whole landscape of things so
what you're describing um is incredible
but I think makes a ton of sense yeah so
we have the social transfer pain Evangel
G's here we're working on and there's a
little bit of evidence in the literature
suggesting this might work and then I'll
talk about reward circuitry and maybe
MDMA and is is it in pathogen or not and
how that might influence therapeutic
efforts for autism we're working on
behavioral models we're asking the
question will one Mouse behave
to give another mouse a reward so it's
the mouse that's behaving that has to
press a bar or nose poke or even
experience the shock will the mouse do
that simply to get give one of its
buddies a reward pure altruism and yeah
it's pure it's it's what we call it
generosity a generosity assay and early
days it looks like it might be working
we I don't
um and that's a generosity assay we can
also ask the question will a mouse work
so another mouse doesn't get a shock
doesn't get hurt which is compassion and
I think these things are going to be
working and whether you want to call
that empathy I would call that those are
behaviors I like to use the term
behavioral antecedents of how we Define
empathy in human beings and the
connection to reward circuitry and in
the little bit of work
we have done on this is we presented
evidence that these behaviors we call
the Social transfer of pain one Mouse
experiencing pain just because it's
hanging out with another mouse the
social transfer of analgesia a mouse in
pain getting some pain relief from
hanging out with another mouse in pain
who has that pain relief it seems to
involve one component of the complex
brain mechanisms seems to involve
a part of the brain called the anterior
cingulate cortex which human brain
Imaging studies suggest are is activated
during empathic human responses and the
projections of that area into the
nucleus accumbens that's the connection
um and we're interested in whether
neuromodulators like dopamine and
serotonin May influence these circuitry
these connections that are involved in
these in quotes empathic behaviors
etc etc and we think drugs can be used
as probes of those kinds of
neuromodulatory mechanisms I hope this
is all making sense it makes a excellent
sense and it's fascinating um I'm not
one to suggest experiments to uh
colleagues in areas where I don't work
but I I I'm going to anyway yeah please
um One You're a really smart guy I will
value your suggestions you know I love
the the motivational backbone to what
you're describing here because I agree
the world has a lot of issues and what
it could be more important than to
increase the amount of empathy and
compassion in the world but one thing
that we know inhibits empathy and
compassion is one's own challenges and
struggles and so I'm wondering if
there's a way to introduce something to
this behavioral Paradigm such that
the working to provide another animal
relief from pain one animal working to
provide relief of another animal in pain
or a animal working to provide pleasure
reward for another animal yeah you know
if it could be scaled with how
inconvenient that work is right like if
I'm very hungry I mean we're all taught
to put our own oxygen mask on first in
some way too so that we don't all die so
to speak but you know I grew up for
instance with a one parent my mother was
the kind of person who would see at that
time there were far fewer homeless
people on the street maybe they were all
institutionalized I don't know
um but
if she saw a homeless person on the
street of the town we lived in she would
literally pull over give them money find
hotels she had homeless people living in
hotels all over the town we lived in it
was crazy and we couldn't get anywhere
that was the problem is we would never
arrive anywhere on time and that's my
excuse for always being late I was
positively reinforced her being late I
always run late and I always run
incredible right just a very strong
sense of social Phantom connection that
kind of thing but in any case you know
some people are like that like she could
not
experience any um even modicum of
inconvenience for helping others whereas
I think most of us feel like if I'm
rushing to catch a flight and I see
someone who's struggling I'm probably
going to help them if they're in acute
pain or it seems like a dire
circumstance but let's be honest most
people
are probably going to prioritize their
own stress and and priorities for lack
of a better word when
the situation often calls for us to set
those aside and tend to people that are
suffering so if there was a way to
introduce the um the inter a probe of
the interplay of circuitries that
involve how convenient or inconvenient
it is like if we're well fed it's pretty
easy to go out and gather and distribute
food for others but if we're hungry we
tend to focus on our own hunger we so
first
um you know in full disclosure even
though I'm studying empathy and
compassion I can look in the mirror and
say I probably don't practice it nearly
as much as I should I'm thinking of your
example if I was late for a plane
I'm not sure I would stop and help
somebody and I'm not saying it depends
on the on what sort of suffering yeah
exactly I mean if they're hemorrhaging
on the side of course we all would of
course I'm tired right you might think
oh goodness like do I have time yeah
yeah exactly right and so I'm not proud
of that statement but back to your
question
yes I think absolutely we can design
experiments where after we've
established the basic phenomenology then
we can take our subject animal or Mouse
and put it in just to certain
circumstances if it's hungry itself will
it work is hard to give another animal I
mean it's a good question because I'm
not sure what the outcome will be in one
could predict it might work harder
because it understands the hunger and
quotes more I love it or it could be
of course it's not going to work hard
for another animal to get a food reward
because it's starving itself and it
needs to take care of itself first it's
a great question we're also asking
questions about do you have to know your
buddy Mouse right do you is it are you
more likely to behave in a generous or
compassionate way if you grew up with
that Mouse you know in the way our mice
grow up in academic environments and if
it's a stranger how will you behave
how will you behave if you had a fight
with that Mouse previously and what if
you had
and and it also matters did you win the
fight or did you lose the fight right
you're Pro you know intuitively as we
probably would all guess I'm more likely
to help somebody I defeated in a fight
previously because I'm the you know and
the hierarchy I'm the dominant one I'm
probably less likely if that person beat
me up so all these are great questions I
think we can study them
um I also think there are ways we can
study these kinds of interactions in
human subjects
um not that I am going to do that myself
but someone at Stanford will yeah yeah
so I think there's also an opportunity
and I'm happy to discuss how
neuromodulators like in particular
serotonin but also perhaps dopamine and
oxytocin May influence the brain the
circuitry in the brain mechanisms that
are mediating what I term empathic
behaviors
let's return to autism all right
does autism involve a lack of empathy
does autism involve a restructuring of
the reward system around social
interactions
um maybe considering the second question
first I could imagine for instance that
there are variations in brain wiring
that would make it such that
um a kid who then becomes an adult gets
a tremendous amount of reward from
um I don't know math of Designing mugs
um any number of activities but that
through some variation in brain wiring
social interactions spending time with
friends is just not as socially
rewarding it just doesn't feel good in
the in the moment doesn't necessarily
feel bad but it's not selected for and
um is there any evidence that that's the
case in children who are classified as
Autistic or having autism
um I I am I want to be clear I am not a
a world expert on pathophysiology of
individuals with autism spectrum
disorder I have read some of the
literature I do study
Mouse models of genetically based Autism
Spectrum Disorder so the answer is yes
there there have been Imaging studies
and again
so your audience certain members your
audience don't get mad or remember our
earlier conversation we we made the
point that autism spectrum disorder is a
highly heterogeneous
set of Behavioral symptoms with wide
variation in how these symptoms manifest
in each individual so we cannot make
blanket statements that individuals with
autism Spectra Spectrum Disorder are
this or that but there are studies both
in human beings and mice that suggest
that the reinforcing component of a
social interaction
is much less or lacking in our models of
autism spectrum spectrum disorder and
certain individuals an important point
is is that
just genetically wired was that because
in their early experiences they weren't
able to get the sensory stimuli that's
tell them this is a reinforcing social
experience unknown
um or at least those are topics that I
think are worthy of Investigation
um do individuals or mice with autism
spectrum disorder
lack or do not have the capacity or the
same
experience of empathy again a very
complex Topic in question and
it's very likely for some individuals
the answer is yes meaning they they do
lack some of the neural mechanisms that
allow them but that probably doesn't
apply to everybody I can say
in our Mouse models of social
interactions and our Mouse models of in
quotes empathy in these um
are my on my show deficits
um and those deficits can be rescued
meaning improved upon by manipulations
of certain neuromodulatory systems in
this case the serotonin system
by giving drugs including a drug called
MDMA or ecstasy
um so I hope I'm answering your question
I I think
these are worthwhile
subjects for investigation I think
there's a lot of
value in studying them let's go back to
serotonin in the nucleus accumbens um we
will get into this in a bit more detail
when we discuss MDMA but I've now spent
a lot of time with a recent paper of
yours that really which one of the MDMA
yeah that part of Boris yeah the door
that that parsed the relative roles of
dopamine in the nucleus versus serotonin
nucleus the commons by the way
um folks uh by time this episode comes
out an episode all about MDMA itself and
it's a modes of action will have already
aired and you can find that but even if
you haven't heard that
um you know MDMA is an amazing molecule
because it profoundly increases
um dopamine
and that's why the word methamphetamine
is actually in MDMA
um still a surprise to many people to
hear that but it also robustly increases
serotonin transmission and what I love
about the paper from your lab that
explored this is that it at least by my
read of the data it showed very
convincingly that its serotonin released
in the nucleus accumbens that's
responsible for the pro-social effects
of MDMA whereas oxytocin this thing we
talked about earlier that everyone
assumes is the pair bonding molecule the
molecule of love both in humans now if
there's a study in humans and in the
mouse work that you've done doesn't seem
to play as prominent to role in the
social uh enhancement that MDMA causes
and the reason I'm asking this in the
context of autism is that for a long
time there was excitement about the idea
that oxytocin nasal sprays might make
autistic kids more excited about social
interactions more tuned to social
interactions first question is is there
any evidence that increasing oxytocin in
a child or adult with autism makes them
somehow more social or Desiring more
social connections
I'm not aware of any I I I don't think
the I think it is a it is a worthwhile
it has been studied I I don't think we
can close the door on the potential
therapeutic uses of oxytocin
from the the people I know who are much
more expert in this than I am I think
most of the clinical trials have been
pretty disappointing with you know a lot
of hope that intranasal oxytocin would
promote more positive pro-social
experiences I don't think the door is
shut yet there may be
different ways of administrating it
administering it there may be ways of
making a different type of oxytocin that
might be beneficial I have a colleague
at Stanford who's actually looking at a
related neuropeptide called vasopressin
and she's finding some potential benefit
from that and vasopressin and oxytocin
are closely related to each other they
can even activate some of the same what
we call receptors in the brain so I
don't think the door is closed on the
possibility of oxytocin or related
therapeutic agents having some
therapeutic potential the evidence as
far as I'm aware is not there yet in
terms of MDMA
again complicated story
um as you pointed out mgma
it's it's major molecular targets don't
want to get too technical here are
the serotonin vacuum cleaner the the
molecule that's vacuums up serotonin and
the dopamine vacuum cleaner the molecule
that
vacuums up and excuse my language sucks
up dopamine when it's released
um
because it's an amphetamine derivative
as you point correctly pointed out it
not only prevents these proteins we call
them these molecules these vacuum
cleaners from vacuuming up the dopamine
and serotonin when it's released it
actually causes it how do I don't want
to use the term the the terminals to
vomit out dopamine and serotonin that's
what I say on the uh all right
synaptic release I'm known for when my
solo episodes for when I talk about
synaptic release I'll um I'll say that
they they vomit out so what amphetamine
derivative you work on synaptic
transmission so it's almost an insult
what mgma does is that it actually calls
what's known as a reverse transport it
actually causes it not only prevents the
vacuum cleaners from
sucking up the dopamine and serotonin it
causes it to spew out dopamine and
serotonin so imagine if your vacuum
cleaner started the pressure in your
vacuum cleaner reversed and all the dirt
you collected started being spewed out
now the one difference for MDMA
and you know it's a fascinating topic I
hope we have time to talk about is why
does MDMA
qualitatively for most people give give
human subjects a different experience
than cocaine or methane or especially
methamphetamine presumably it's the fact
that there's so much serotonin exactly
and so if you actually get in and this
is why
for your audiences this is why hardcore
molecular science can actually teach us
something about
complex human behavioral phenomena such
as
social interactions and addiction at
least the hypothesis we propose and
others in the field it's not just you
know science is not done in isolation so
I want to give credit where creditors do
we did not Define the following that
MDMA
affects the serotonin system more than
the dopamine system so it's not equal
it's not 50 50. maybe it's 70 30 80 20
and that's because the molecule itself
of MDMA
again I'm trying not to use language has
a it binds to it it has a higher
Affinity it likes to bind to and
influence the serotonin vacuum cleaner
more than the dopamine vacuum cleaner
it's still affecting both but it's not
50 50. it's more whatever 70s 70
serotonin 30 dopamine
um and then it does influence oxytocin
in very complex ways
um which is a further technical
discussion
um
it was just a nice paper that came out
that reported that serotonin release in
a hypothalamic structure which again the
hypothalamus you can explain to your
listeners
structure above the roof of your mouth
responsible for a sex temperature
control uh feeding and satiety and a
bunch of other things critical
um and uh yeah and it's a home of oxy
neurons that produce oxygen thank you so
this paper reported that when serotonin
is released in the hypothalamus it
activates and causes the release of
oxytocin that's in the hypothalamus our
work in the reward circuitry suggested
oxytocin so that's serotonin Upstream of
oxytocin and the hypothalamus in the
where we were looking in the accumbens
it was the opposite oxytocin caused the
release of Serotonin so the point to
your listeners is the brains
unfortunately complicated
we like it's tractable we like to come
up with General hypotheses and
principles but sometimes the devil's in
the details and we really need to probe
deeper so back to your question about
our previous paper and dopamine and
serotonin so what we are what we
proposed Which is far from nail down is
that MDMA because it is an amphetamine
derivative does influence dopamine
release and dopamine the dopamine system
and
some of my colleagues in the MDMA field
who I respect enormously don't like me
to say this but I'm going to say it
anyhow
remember earlier in the podcast we
talked about different substances having
addictive liabilities doesn't mean that
substances automatically addictive
doesn't mean it's automatically not it's
a Continuum and I would argue that MDMA
does have a some addictive liability
because it is an amphetamine derivative
it feels good and it feels good and so
there are individuals that especially uh
you know as your listeners may know and
the Amaze has gotten a lot of attention
because it's in a therapeutic trial that
looks very promising for as an adjunct
to psychotherapy for post-traumatic
stress disorder and the the FDA the part
of our government that
approves or disapproves the legal
distribution of therapeutic drugs may
end up approving MDMA for certain uses
the point being is that once it if it
gets approved
my personal feeling is that you will
have some addictive liability it also
has this very powerful
what you and I might term Andrew a
pro-social effect
some people even call it an empathogen
that's a little controversial meaning it
enhances your capacity for empathy to to
experience the emotional state of
another individual to want to understand
that person's experiences and emotional
state
um and our what we've suggested is that
the addictive liability is mostly
although not solely being mediated by
its actions on the dopamine system
whereas it's positive more pro-social
effects and perhaps it's empathogenic
effects are more likely to be mediated
by its interactions with the serotonin
system in in the in this reward
circuitry and we're actually doing a lot
of work to test that hypothesis we're
actually testing MDMA in these
behavioral models of empathy in mice
um and it looks like our hypothesis is
being supported the other thing just to
drive your your listeners crazy about
sorry listeners how complex the brain is
if you think neither you nor I were
consulted at the design phase and so we
don't have to apologize for the brain's
complexity because I don't trust me as a
scientist I wish I could keep things as
simple as possible that's what good
science is it turns out the serotonin
serotonin is produced by neurons in
another part of the brain with this
wonderful name called the dorsal raphae
nucleus and it turns out the serotonin
neurons talk to the dopamine neurons
and influence the dopamine neurons and
um so it's again the point we made
earlier in your podcast even though it's
fun and useful both for your listeners
and as scientists to think about these
powerful chemical Messengers in
isolation because that's how we can make
progress scientifically it's how your
audience can understand some of the
concepts that have been elucidated from
brain research over the decades
but they don't work in isolation they
influence each other they communicate
with each other we're actually doing
studies showing that
serotonin release in the accumbens
actually modulates dopamine release so
it gets crazy complicated but you can
still develop simplistic hypotheses like
as I was saying about MDMA where you
know abuse addictive liability and some
of it's reinforcing qualities which you
just mentioned MDMA a lot of people find
it fun to take it is probably mostly via
me being mediated via the dopamine
system and some of its social effects
although and
are being mediated by the serotonin
system we're actually doing studies to
figure out whether they're reinforcing
component of a social experience
requires that dopamine release probably
does that's what I'm most interested in
really in the context of MDMA and we
should just mention because we we do
um uh like to mention these caveats uh
yes the ex and I can say this because I
participated in a trial with MDMA it it
is a very pleasant experience it's
certainly not for everybody it still is
a schedule one drug at this moment
absolutely um so you can go to jail for
possessing and uh or selling in fact it
was a big bust recently in Canada and
another one in Brussels
um a large amounts of MDMA collected
those people are probably going to go to
prison for a long period of time so you
you do you don't want to take it or
possess it it's illegal we're talking
about clinical trials here but also
um the fentanyl issue there's a lot of
things and I was just going to mention
to yourself so we'd be remiss if we
didn't eventually a lot of people are
dying thinking that they're taking one
drug when they're taking an so so we are
not encouraging the use of these but I
will say that the subjective experience
of MDMA provided it's done in a the
appropriate clinical setting it's
actually MDMA doesn't contain other
things
um dosed correctly Etc
um
is a pleasant one for sure and my my
sense is that
um the dopamine release uh is
reinforcing the experience that the
context of Serotonin is providing with a
social context right and and the word
context there becomes important when we
think about back to the 90s when there
are a lot of raves and people were also
you know getting um I guess positive
feedback from the interactions they were
having dancing all night partying with
friends Etc I mean I think that
um returning to the issue of autism and
the role of Serotonin so
in autism there seems to be less of a uh
reinforcement pathway for certain kinds
of social interactions
um in some individuals with autism
um and I'm aware that there are some
prescription treatments for autism that
capitalize on the serotonergic system
and dopamine system so um is it
Phentermine it's my knowledge the only
FDA approved
pharmacologic therapeutic for
individuals with autism spectrum
disorder is actually oh God I'm just
blanking it's not a serotonergic drug
I'm I have to look it up I I want to say
risperidone for agitation
um there is no
drug for
for lack of a better term the social
deficits there's no FDA approved drug if
you look at the literature
psychiatrists and individuals with gr
with good intention have tested the
utility of traditional serotonergic
drugs like Prozac ssris there are drugs
known as snris drugs that influence
serotonin release and another
neuromodulator that you know well
norepinephrine and at least well done
clinical trials which in my view as an
academic are very important none of them
have showed efficacy having said that
there are several companies and full
disclosure Here I Am the founder of a
small biotech called maplight
Therapeutics and I'm not advertising
from applight I'm just doing a full
disclosure it was founded with Carl
dieseroth who you've had on your podcast
and an entrepreneur in San Francisco
named Carolee nikolich
and we have a phase two trial phase two
trial means it's a safe drug we've done
all the safety
work and it's a drug that targets a
subtype of receptor for serotonin
serotonin works on many different I I
don't know what word can I use other
than receptor no listeners of this
podcast probably be familiar with
receptors there are parking spots for uh
for molecules
um yes that the paper you I was
referencing earlier from your lab it
talked about serotonin 1B receptors
particularly important and so and the
point being is you know I do have an
interest in this on can you use the type
of discoveries we've made in mice might
it actually have any relevance to human
sub human beings in particular those
who some of which have some sort of
sociability deficits
other companies are pursuing this too so
MDMA itself there has been I don't know
if it's ongoing there's a well-known
organization I don't know if you've ever
had anybody from maps in this the
multi-disciplinary association for
psychedelic studies maps deserves a lot
of credit for being a Pioneer in saying
in particular with MDMA promoting the
idea that you know this drug deserves
rigorous and ethical study
um that that's at least my view
um
in maps which was founded by a
individual named Rick doblin has
deserves enormous credit for their
30-year effort to make it
allowed and legal to actually study MDMA
the point I'm making is I know maps and
perhaps others have done some small
trials studying MDMA in individuals high
functioning individuals with some form
of social anxiety
I'm saying this because this is public
there's another company called Mind Med
which is one of the publicly traded
psychedelic companies and this is on
their website full disclosure I am on
their scientific Advisory Board
they are gearing up to do a trial of a
I don't want to get too technical of a
certain form of MDMA there are two
different types of MDMA that they have
these horrible names called enantiomers
so the MDMA that is used for clinical
trials that Maps MDMA is a molecule and
it has mirror images of itself and one
one has the name rmdma and one has the
name smdma and they're they're called
the enantiomers because they're mirror
images of each other and other labs over
the years not my lab I deserve no credit
for this have done some studies to
suggest
that the s enantiomer
is the one that has a higher interaction
with the dopamine system and the r
enantiomer has a higher interaction with
the serotonin system interesting
um if you look at the the literature on
autism spectrum disorder in human
subjects there's a bunch of papers
suggesting
serotonergic systems are malfunctioning
in
individuals with autism spectrum
disorder and if you look at
reviews I've written or any of my papers
we probably cite some of the reviews
it's clear that serotonin is playing
some role in social interactions at
least in mice and almost certainly in
humans as well it's hard to imagine
Based on data from everything from ssris
to neurotoxic lesions of the human brain
Etc that it's not also playing at least
a similar role in here right and I I
fully agree with that and and as we were
discussing there's a there's a modestly
extensive clinical literature meaning
literature from Human subjects
suggesting that some aspects of
brain systems that utilize serotonin as
one of their
signaling molecules one of their
neuromodulatory mechanisms may not be
functioning in some populations of
individuals with autism spectrum
disorder So based on that based on my
lab's work on the role of serotonin in
modifying rewards circuitry its role in
pro-social behaviors and
the biggest clue which I think you would
agree with Andrew is this drug MDMA I
mean this is why I am not a druggie
myself I am a child of the 60s and 70s
so I did which means I'm 20 years older
than you Andrew I did experiment like
everybody of my generation with
psychoactive substances in the 70s so I
don't want to lie about my experiences I
also would say like many neuroscientists
my experiences with psychoactive
substances
stimulated my interest in Neuroscience
how do these substances work why when I
get the when I was a young kid the first
time I got drunk on beer why is that
happening but more seriously
I use drugs in my research as powerful
probes of brain function with the
advantage that
and now I'm talking scientists to
scientists with you Andrew they have
molecular targets that we can manipulate
in rigorous ways we can figure out where
in the brain they act using the modern
tools of Neuroscience which your
audience
may not know about I'm saying this to
you conditional knockout mice rescue
experiments we can do all those fancy
stuff
and we can use drugs to study even
things as complicated as empathy and I
really do believe that's why I've been
interested in MDMA for decades is
there's a clue there how does a drug
that has molecular Targets in the
dopamine neuromodulatory system in the
serotonin neuromodulator Choice system
have such a powerful effect
which
is a relatively specific on social
interactions it doesn't make you want to
go eat more Donuts it doesn't
um
I don't know for me there's a clue there
there's something really important from
that phenomenological observation in the
human experiences that we can learn from
I completely agree about MDMA and um you
know we've done a couple podcasts about
psilocybin and by extension LSD because
even though there are differences there
psilocybin LSD
as far as we understand largely work
through
um you know activation of the serotonin
2A receptor broadening the brain network
connectivity so again it's serotonin
serotonin serotonin but different
receptors very different subjective
experience
um and I guess perhaps the best way to
describe it is that LSD and psilocybin
are almost always considered mystical in
the in their subjective effects whereas
um MDMA can be an empathogen and actogen
um and so serotonin in acting to through
different receptor systems impacting and
creating very different subjective
experiences I also agree I think MDMA is
particularly interesting for the
neuroscientist
um perhaps also because at least to my
knowledge there is no substance in
nature no plant no mushroom no ergot no
um any no mold
um that
creates this increase in dopamine and
serotonin simultaneously MDMA is a
synthesized molecule and so it may be
one of the again highlighting all the
safety issues and things we talked about
before it may be one of the great at
least experimental probes of the brain
that humans have developed and it may be
one of the great therapeutic probes that
folks like maps have are now doing such
fantastic work on so I'm very excited
about what's happening with the research
on MDMA and I'm so glad that your
laboratory has parsed some of the
relative roles of Serotonin The
receptors involved it since we mentioned
serotonin 2A for psilocybin and LSD we'd
be remiss if we didn't say that this
wonderful paper that we will provide a
link to in the show note captions by the
way folks
um that Rob malenka here's labyrinths
focused on the serotonin 1B receptor so
it even just differences in receptor
subtypes leading to profoundly different
subjective outcomes I I find that to be
uh just one of the most important areas
that one could even think about let
alone work on uh thank you I appreciate
the compliment I will also say unlike
everything we're finding it's not all
about only serotonin 1B but that's as
you know there are again pointing to the
the amazing and Powerful complexity of
the human brain or the mammalian brain
There are 16 different serotonin
parking spots or receptors that are
distributed in different brain areas in
complex ways and so that's daunting but
it also offers
possibilities for developing very novel
therapeutic agents that that activate or
inhibit these in complex ways hopefully
for therapeutic benefit
so before we conclude I'm very curious
to get your opinion on what you see as
the landscape of the work on
psychedelics and MDMA which isn't really
a classic psychedelic but all these
drugs that as you pointed out during
your youth were used recreationally and
for mind exploration and expansion are
now being probed as potential
Therapeutics for various mental health
challenges as well as potentially
expanding Consciousness empathy and all
all of that I mean not getting into the
details of you know the the legal issues
that have to be overcome not even
necessarily talking about the clinical
trials or the people doing the work in
different Laboratories but just
I have to imagine this is must amuse
tickle surprise you I mean how do you
feel about what you're seeing now
because it is a very exciting time for
these compounds
um it tickles me and excites me with the
appropriate caution
um so
I do think drugs are very powerful
probes of brain function I think this
class of drug which as you correctly
pointed out people use the term
psychedelics
scientifically when pursuing their re
um
understanding their therapeutic
potential their mechanism of action it's
more useful to divide them up into
different categories the classic
hallucinogens which are LSD and
psilocybin the intactor and pathogens
which is MDMA which is really a
qualitatively different drug there are
other substances which we we don't have
time to talk about like ibogaine and
Ayahuasca which are very complex and
peyote but nevertheless I am tickled and
excited as a child of the 60s and 70s
but I am also
not Evangelical about their use and
their therapeutic potential so as you
can imagine what I'm going to say I
think they should be the subject of
rigorous sophisticated and most
importantly ethical research
um I I think we could learn a lot about
how the brain works and it's amazing
capabilities I think we could I think
they may notice I say may have
therapeutic potential
but I do not think they're going to be
miracle cures and I do worry as somebody
who lived through the 60s and 70s and
watched because of the leery
um the history with Timothy Leary and
his colleagues and the political
landscape of how they were being used
and promoted I am cautious that
these substances need to be studied
scientifically and rigorously and I hope
that's the case and I want to caution
your audience that not everybody should
take these substances they are not
miracle cures and while they certainly
may be of benefit to certain individuals
who are suffering and they certainly may
provide unusual and in quotes mystical
experiences for certain individuals
I am very concerned that there are
individuals out there that will gain
access to these substances and have very
bad experiences because anybody who grew
up in the 60s and 70s knows all about
bad trips
and truth be told I have had a bad trip
or two in the 70s and I'm glad I did
because it made me
I have no idea what a suicidal
depression feels like where you are
experiencing such a Darkness such a lack
of hope that a rational decision is to
end one's life but and I think the
closest I ever came to that experience
is a bad trip on LSD and I do have
concerns that if you look at the
clinical trials that have been done the
welcome done not the anecdotal I went
and saw some psychedelic therapist that
a friend recommended and it did wonders
for me but the well-controlled clinical
trials that are being done by certain
biotechs some academic institutions they
have very strict
what are known as inclusionary and
exclusionary criteria about who is
allowed to participate in the subject
and they rule out a lot of people so I
don't mean to be overly cautious but
I do worry that
if some people take these substances and
bad things happen it will slow down the
excitement that's currently happening
and it will make it more difficult for
serious
human subjects researchers pre-clinical
researchers to study these substances in
the way they deserve to be studied so
[Music]
I hope that
articulates my viewpoint I think it's a
it does and thank you for that Viewpoint
it's an important counterbalance on a
lot of the excitement that we hear about
these days I think the state of Kentucky
just recently decided to give 42 million
dollars from the opioid lawsuit
settlement with Purdue Pharmaceuticals
to the study of ibogaine so there's a
lot happening you know and I I you know
just to be clear I think there's no
problem with that and I actually would
support that as long as the studies of
ibogaine are done thoughtfully carefully
and ethically I see no problem with
testing its efficacy in certain
mental illnesses and addiction and it's
act it's actually a topic I know a
little bit about that we'll save that
for another time right well
first off I want to thank you for coming
here and sharing your knowledge with all
of us for me it's been a real thrill and
I also just want to thank you for the
incredible amount of work that you've
done over the years I know it's still
ongoing here by no means uh retiring uh
who knows I certainly hope not but
um I'm sure the listeners have
um now in a clear picture of the
enormous number of contributions and
areas you've worked everywhere from as I
mentioned earlier neuroplasticity at the
seller level molecular level addiction
um work relating to social cognition and
social interactions rather
um as it pertains to autism models and
now psychedelics and empathy and on and
on and again train so many prominent
scientists in our field and to take time
out of your schedule to come sit here
with us and share some of that knowledge
and stimulate our thinking and as you
mentioned raise still more questions
that need to be resolved is a real
privilege so thank you ever so much and
indeed as just mentioned we'd love to
have you back again for another time all
I can say is I want to thank you for
having me I was a little
hesitant or nervous about coming here
and now I want to come back so yeah
that was a blast what I just did with
you and I'd be happy to continue this
conversation anytime so thank you for
your very sophisticated and thoughtful
questions to be continued to be
continued thank you for joining me for
today's discussion all about
neuroplasticity reward systems social
connection and empathy with Dr Robert
malenka if you're learning from and or
enjoying this podcast please subscribe
to our YouTube channel that's a terrific
zero cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review if you have questions
for me or comments about the podcast or
guests that you'd like me to consider
hosting on the huberman Lab podcast
please put those in the comments section
on YouTube I do read all the comments in
addition please check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast not so
much on today's episode but on many
previous episodes of The huberman Lab
podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like
enhancing sleep hormone support and
focus and much more the huberman Lab
podcast has partnered with momentous
supplements if you're interested in
learning more about the supplements
discussed on the huberman Lab podcast
please go to live momentous spelled ous
that's livmomentis.com huberman if
you're not already following me on
social media I am hubermanlab on all
social media platforms so that means
Instagram Twitter Facebook and Linkedin
on all those platforms I post content
some of which overlaps with the content
of the huberman Lab podcast but much of
which is distinct from the content on
the huberman Lab podcast if you haven't
already subscribed to the huberman Lab
podcast neural network newsletter the
neural network newsletter is a monthly
newsletter it is completely zero cost
and it includes protocols or what we
call tool kits that you can download so
for instance toolkits for enhancing
sleep a toolkit for Learning and
neuroplasticity toolkits for fitness and
for much more to sign up for the neural
network newsletter simply go to
hubermanlab.com go to the menu and
scroll down to newsletter you sign up by
providing your email but I want to be
clear that we do not share your email
with anybody thank you once again for
joining me for today's discussion with
Dr Dr Robert malenka and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in science
[Music]